[Music]
you're listening to radio
sputnik telling
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
the coronavirus is vanquished officially
at midnight
i don't know if anyone has told it boris
johnson will not be
celebrating because he is self-isolating
admittedly at his country retreat at
checkers
and if you're going to self-isolate
trust me that's the place to do it
we'll be visiting london politics
washington politics will be visiting
south africa visiting haiti
visiting cuba will even be visiting
the moon on the anniversary of the moon
landing
or did we really ever land on the moon
one of my friends said
just before we came on air it never
happened
i'll be talking to an expert about
that the situation in world politics
continues to be particularly volatile
in places where volatility wasn't quite
expected like cuba like south africa
we'll be talking to ronnie castros the
former minister
of intelligence in the anc government
in that country a former military
commander
we'll see what he thinks of what's going
on there now
talking to an expert about haiti where
the president
has just been murdered and nobody yet
knows
entirely by whom and talking
of course about cuba about which i
myself
have much to say on this weekend
the global premiere of my new film
killing kelly all of that is coming up
over the next
three hours so fasten your seatbelt
this is rock and roll radio
with pictures it's going to be a bumpy
ride
because after all it is the mother of
all
talk shows
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education
you can get for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
welcome to the mother of all talk shows
the college of knowledge
the open university of the airwaves
where there are no
tuition fees and where you are
positively encouraged
to talk back to the teacher or be an
uneducated one
such as myself your calls your tweets
your emails are welcome throughout the
show
and we'll get as many of you on air as
we
possibly can you can listen to us in
crystal clarity
on fm in the washington dc area
105.5 other magic numbers there
you can listen on am from coast to coast
from burning city to burning city
right throughout the united states you
can listen
across the entire world on
sputniknews.com
thanks to the wonders of algorithms
internet and you may be one of those
half a million or more who every single
week now
are watching as well as listening to the
show
and if you are doing so on facebook
please
share it with all of your friends on
facebook
right now because that algorithm is
always busy you can watch on my facebook
page on rt's multiple
facebook pages ditto on my youtube
channel do subscribe
if you're watching on there we still
haven't got
our medal from uh youtube for getting
over a hundred thousand
subscribers i don't know if they've just
forgotten about us or whether they're
hoping we'll go away hope they don't
hope that too much because they can
always make us
go away which is why i'm encouraging
everyone to follow me
on my telegram channel you can
watch on telegram you can watch on
instagram
uh at least the opening remarks you can
watch
as an amazing number of you do live on
your telephone
on twitter but whatever
that's a t dot me george george galloway
is the telegram channel t dot me
forward slash george galloway do uh
follow me on that because one day that
might be
the only place that you can follow me
maybe i'm being pessimistic but the
rigors of the social media
oligarchs were visited on the united
states public just this week and we'll
be talking to rachel blevins
the inimitable rachel blevins about that
the president of the united states has a
whole unit
in the white house getting people banned
off facebook
getting their videos taken down getting
their posts taken down their pages
closed all the while demanding freedom
of the internet in cuba
now cuba is very very important to me
i wrote a book about fidel castro the
fidel castro handbook
signed copies of which are still
available at my
shop though they are running out now and
we won't be republishing them so
if you want one you best act quickly
i happen to believe that fidel castro is
the greatest man i ever met
by a country mile in all of my life i
happen to
love cuba and its revolution and its
achievements
from the bottom of my heart
it is an agony to me to see
the gold-toothed emigres gusanos
in miami in florida thinking that they
are dancing
on the grave of the cuban revolution i
don't myself
believe it for a minute another would
you if you saw the crowds
in support of the cuban revolution
out on the streets of havana today
i think this is the misfiring
color revolution that the united states
has sparked
but it presumably pressages more efforts
so the period of the obama
biden administration of normalization
of relations with cuba with president
obama you may recall
visiting cuba meeting fidel castro
appear to be history and yet
joe biden was the vice president of the
man
that normalized relations with cuba
you've got to
expect that cuba will come under
unrelenting
attack and destabilization but hey
that's been happening for 60 years it's
just that there weren't
any social media pictures of it
cuba's achievements are very clear it
has
a longer life expectancy than the united
states
of america it has fewer
infant mortalities than the united
states
of america it has a better health
service
than the united states of america it has
higher rates of literacy
than the united states of america no
children
in cuba none zero go to work instead of
school but 120
million children go to work instead of
school
every day in the rest of the developing
world but not one of them in cuba
perhaps these are the reasons why the
united states hates cuba
so much but we've got to ask the
question
what will be the next move i'm sure the
cubans
are asking that right now one man that
we have on the show
who will i think have a point of view on
this
is the former military commander
of the guerrilla fighters that brought
down the apartheid system
in south africa and later became the
first
minister for intelligence in the
anc's south african government
now south africa means a very great deal
to me too if you
have been a long time follower of me you
know
of my small role in the struggle against
apartheid which included
travelling the length and breadth of
apartheid south africa
under the direction of the african
national
congress led then by nelson mandela from
behind bars
in paul's moore prison and in paulsmoor
hospital
mandela was very clear about how
apartheid was finally defeated
he could have gone anywhere in the world
once he was released from
the apartheid dungeons but he went
directly to
cuba because of the role that cuba had
played
in fighting at the apartheid armies
uh in angola and in mozambique
which helped to break the back of
apartheid power
in south africa and mandela went there
first specifically to say that
so apartheid was supported of course
by the united states and great britain
and much of the western capitalist world
it was defeated between the hammer
of the armed struggle of which my guest
ronnie castro's was such a key figure
and the anvil of worldwide
opposition to the horrors the ugliness
of
apartheid imagine then the feelings of
sadness
of me and much more importantly of
people who sacrificed much more
to bring about democratic rule in south
africa
that the country appears to be
disappearing in a vortex of
violence of civil disorder of looting of
killing
and of general murder
and mayhem 200 people have been killed
in the last week
in south africa many of them shot
by shopkeepers whilst
looting others shot by the security
services
others killed by the uh
private security apparatus which is
i'm afraid to say a ubiquitous now
in the new south africa so we'll be
talking to ronnie castro's
not just about south africa but about
cuba
also and you can't talk about cuba
without talking about
haiti because haiti is what cuba
would have been if not for the glorious
victory of castro and the
26th july movement back in 1959
the fate of haiti a sink
of misery of drug addiction of rampant
criminality
of gang warfare of racism
of repair regular
coups against the rigged
electoral choices thrown up by the
haitian elections but as far as i know
the president that was murdered
last week by persons unknown
is the first haitian leader literally to
be killed
by gunmen whilst in office
most of the gunmen were colombian
former service personnel colombia is a
key
ally of the united states of america
two of the murderers were
american citizens albeit of haitian
extraction we'll be talking to an editor
of haiti liberty a very considerable
expert kim ives about what's really
going down
in haiti and above all i suppose
what's going to happen next we'll be
talking as i say
uh about american politics about the
extraordinary dimash
of president biden i don't know if he
knew he was there or knew what he was
saying but he accused
the facebook in particular of
killing people by allowing
a modicum of freedom of speech
on their platforms we'll be talking as i
say to
rachel blevins about that we'll be
talking
about the anniversary of the landing on
the moon
if it happened but we'll also be talking
about the film i launched at the
everyman cinema
in moswell hill and a big thank you to
them for a most
beautiful venue and a flawlessly
run event the film
is even better than i imagined it to be
i saw it last night in toto for the
first time
because of course i've seen every frame
in it
many many times but i hadn't seen it
sewn
together so beautifully by our
director sean murray the rising star
of irish cinema it's an important film
not just because this is the 18th
anniversary
of dr david kelly's death
almost to the hour almost to the day
not just because david kelly is a human
being that
deserved better than what happened to
him
not just because he left behind a
grieving family
who must i'm sure still be
unclear as to exactly how
he met his end it's important for
all of those reasons
but it's even more important because it
is
an example of the extent to which
that the britain we thought we knew
had begun to disappear under the blair
rule the britain that we thought we knew
which
has been changing even more rapidly
since 2003
the britain where we thought we had
relatively i stress
relatively uncorrupted institutions
uncorrupted courts relatively
uncorrupted police
a relatively uncorrupted system of
inquests and a proper
handling of unexplained deaths
an era in which it
obviously now looking back on it became
clear that we were ruled
by brazen liars there had always been in
politics
a space for terminological inexactitudes
there had always been a history of being
economical with the actuality
one government minister the minister for
war profumo
had had to resign for lying to the house
of commons
back in 1963 about
the fact that he was having an affair
with a call girl
christine keeler fast forward
40 years and it's now clear
we had a prime minister indeed hall
government
that was at the dispatch box lying
through its teeth every day
about the need to invade and occupy iraq
and the need to exclude
to crush maybe even
to kill anyone who stood
in the way of that corruption of
democracy
in our country was dispensable
the blair gang the gang that couldn't
shoot straight
killed a lot of people uh but they
also killed the faith in our
institutions in our system in our
democracy that had been held generation
after generation by the vast majority of
british people my
late father god rest his soul being one
of them who went
to his grave are believing that britain
was the greatest
country in the world and while all those
things
that i've just talked about could be
found in profusion
in every other country in the world
britain was somehow special that when
our prime minister
spoke especially if he was citing
the findings of our intelligence
services next door and across the river
from me
now and listening to every word of
course that i'm saying
that when a prime minister spoke citing
our intelligence
services we had no choice but to believe
them for they
scarcely would lie about something as
important as that would they
well when you see the film which you can
order
right now but don't watch it till after
the show
you can rent it for uh four pound
and you can buy it for six or you can
buy a dvd which will be signed and
posted to you
for 10 pounds the details will be up
later
and i'll be talking to the man whose
courage
some people say i was brave to make the
film maybe a wee bit
but the right honourable norman baker
was much braver
when he wrote the book on which the film
is based
the strange death of dr david kelly
because he wrote it not long
after the demise of the aforementioned
doctor david kelly
we'll be talking to the right honourable
norman baker
on the show in uh i think the final hour
perhaps in the
third hour in the last hour so here's
george's general knowledge question
one in this week if it happened
in 1969 men from the apollo 11 mission
first walked on the moon if they did
who designed their space suits i bet you
don't get this one
was it a playtex b pr card dan
or c bonnie cash in answers
right after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
peter says the afghan people have lost
george
i thought you were better than this to
be honest
give me a call peter tell me what you
mean and oliver says for some reason
george was on the jihadist side when it
came to yugoslavia
and that's the reason i will never trust
him
i fought against the war on yugoslavia
with all my breath and all my heart me
and tony ben and jeremy corbyn
and others were practically the only
people
in this country opposing the war
on yugoslavia the destruction of
yugoslavia
how dare you you imbecile if you have
any guts you'll pick up the phone right
now
and call this show and justify that
utter slander really
and your yoda says love the show best
entertainment
and education on the airwaves
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
well the answer of course to the
question
who designed the spacesuits in 1969
was not bonnie cashin or pr kardan
it was in fact playtex now
talking of such matters uh will you be
wearing a face covering
next week a yes b
no c when asked
to you can vote in that poll on
my twitter handle now as i
uh trailed a moment or two ago i'm
joined now
from south africa uh by an old
friend of mine ronnie castrols a war
hero a guerrilla
fighter a commander a minister in the
african national
congress government and author of
great note some of the best things ever
written
about the freedom struggle in south
africa came out of the pen
of my next guest ronnie castro's ronnie
welcome to the mother of all talk shows
uh it's good to see you again but not in
these circumstances
because alas uh you're not here to talk
about the great days uh you're here to
talk
about the bad days that your country
is going through i wonder if you could
describe
what's been happening and why you think
it has been happening
sure well good evening comrade george
it's great to be with you i've been
glued to
my hearing here as you've presented the
sputnik
show thank you i'm a great fan and
thank you thank you ronnie so much for
your
courage and the way you stand up for the
truth and justice george
you know how it's inspired me thank you
it's been
a horrendous week
in south africa something that
um when we came to power i coupled
apartheid and it was a democratic south
africa
as you well know you visited us often
from 1994 and on this day by the way
which would be the 103rd
anniversary of great man nelson
mandela's birth
18th july 1900
1918 i mean hina madiba
would never ever have dreamed of such a
nightmare striking this
beloved country and it broke out
not unexpectedly the
intelligence service flat-footed and the
police
flat-footed unfortunately driven
by splits and factions within the anc
which has been brought about by
a a jacob zuma who is now
in in orange overalls in a prison cell
as we speak sentenced to 15 months for
content of
court and that came from the highest
apex court in the land of constitutional
court
a grotesque mediocrity actually
who the anc for so long when he came and
basically
uh organized a a coup
a the overthrow of becky who had become
by that time in 2008
uh rather strange especially from the
trade unions in the left
but also from the zuma grouping within
the anc
who were and have been proved and shown
to be
absolutely bent on the criminal
stripping of of state resources
and selling the country to the cheapest
and
the worst kind of bidders the so-called
guptas and so on
so the courts um after zuma has been
attempting
since 2005 to avoid
the courts they've been and are a number
of charges still
pending against him for corruption but
the anc swept that all under the corpus
uh in one of these lame efforts to
pretend
of a paper unity whilst a group
of racketeers were
we were running the country down and
actually hollowing out state
institutions
by zuma in order to serve himself
which is why we have a situation where a
lot of departments are
dislocated dysfunctional and this has
happened with the security services
so zuma gets sentenced
and this racketeering group around him
who still wish to see
his surrogates and that's themselves
coming back to prague and to keep
themselves out of prison cells
because the number of charges pending
against these particular
people are accruing in the long arm of
the law
uh which cyril ramaphosa has infused
with
with renewed strength of the judiciary
which at least in our country
maintains what you were talking about in
britain pre-tony blair and going back
to profumo and i'm old enough to know
about that history then you
you recounted uh george so
he gets sentenced and this grouping
around him very openly
um they will prevent this
over their dead bodies and
making all sorts of statements when he
at the final hour surrends himself to
the police
we've seen from his very own family
on social media statements about
destabilizing the country if jacob zuma
serves the sentence
with that particular political agenda
you've got to connect it to the enormous
and it goes back to medieva and the
compromises from 1994.
um socioeconomic problems
crisis in a country which has inordinate
unemployment it's a figure over 42
percent
by the statistician general in relation
to
younger people up to the age of 25
they've never seen work you take it up
to a majority
you take it up to the 35 years old and
they are part of an unemployed which is
70 in the country with its enormous
poverty
and the yawning gap of comfortable south
africa which is 20
of our people and of course a couple of
percent as elsewhere
in the neo-liberal world with the
corporates and the greed
and the control going back into colonial
and important times
of the economy and we've had
people predicting bred riots explosions
ticking time bombs
so it wasn't a surprise
that the zoo grouping make the threats
go on to social media calling for
protest and a
situation breaks out just over a week
ago
when the first action on the arterial
highway
the economic lifeline of south africa
from the big port of durban
serving the area we're talking about
between durban and johannesburg 70
of the um the economy suddenly
there's an attack on trucking
uh on that highway and something like
the score of trucks get burnt out
a thursday a week ago and then by the
sunday
i'm triggered by statements in social
media etc
you suddenly get this outpouring which
was
absolutely a nightmare of
looting frenzy gone on steroids
and this is where thousands of people
begin ransacking the major malls
shopping centers food supply depots and
warehouses
of the zulu kingdom of kwazulu-natal
and then attendantly and you know south
africa
well george in the
jobu pretoria area again
into areas where migrant workers
terribly poor and suffering but
traditionally locked in
to that zulu kingdom and increasingly
behind the jacob zuma a
narrow nationalist agenda i mean he's
increasingly
become a native zulu in his life again
playing that ethnic card um
it's that blow up and the police are
nowhere to be
seen and this ransacking takes place
uh which strips these food
mills and and the shopping areas
absolutely to the bones and of course in
in the hunting area to a certain degree
so
this is the uproar that's taking place
and government is slow in responding
um the president from a poser a week ago
is on television and he appeals for calm
he appeals for normality
and he says that the military will be
deployed i woke up on monday morning
with the rest of the country because
that speech was made on a
sunday night and we'd been through this
bedlam through the weekend
um and i expected to see you know i was
once a
deputy minister of defense before i
became a minister of intelligence
we expected to see military vehicles on
the roads
not because we in love with a security
approach we saw what happened in london
in britain in 2011 with the
with the uproar and the uprising there
and and so on
uh so there's a time when you do want to
see
your police and at rare moments when
there's anarchy let loose and the dogs
of war are let loose
to see a military support and there was
nothing
and our minister of defense said
in response that she was going to deploy
the almighty number of two thousand
seven hundred and
two thousand seven hundred troops and
that's for
this massive area of kwazulu-natal
and of uh the whole chain a small
province
with 10 million people or more living
within it
[Music]
fast forwarding from metaphor maya
george to try and characterize what's
happened
the president and the security
ministers including the ministry that i
once ran which is
intelligence services now called state
security agency
um the story begins to flow
which is partly true but also
questionable
because we've seen how these things
operate
across britain you're very used to it in
the united states across
europe and africa and latin america all
over
we're immediately in terms of public
civil disorder which can be traced
back and directly
to hunger and employment um
economic hardship any quality which
south africa is suffering to such a
degree because we're part of the whole
free market neo-liberal reagan thatcher
economic system which was adopted
unfortunately in the compromise that
mandiba worked out and then and becky
and right through zuma to ramaposa runs
in this country
so we've had i would say side by
side with a grouping
who lit a political fuse if we can call
it political but
who let this particular fuse in relation
to the connection with zuma's
incarceration
and their threats that he had to be
released otherwise it would be bedlam
you link into that the basic fundamental
route
which gave rise i would say to the
spontaneous
largely spontaneous looting that took
place
of the very poor going and if i use this
in quotes the liberating
of products that they see spewed out of
them
all the time about commodification and
the right kind of
gucci wear and you've made reference to
the spacesuits and so on
in those shop windows and on television
screens
and basically looking to find a month's
free supply of groceries
you know the ministers who have said oh
it's not that it can't be
because look at the people taking away
the huge
flat tv screens and even car
tires you know utter imbecilic ministers
um and and spokespeople representing
government
who can't see that if you're looking to
offset
hunger and poverty and you come across a
set of car tires in a showroom
of course you're going to translate that
into porridge and bread and milk on the
table for your kids
so there's that whole amalgam of what i
would
say to you is a perfect storm
which occurred in south africa to a
point
because one saving grace
it's not national that we've seen it's
confined to two
provinces there are nine provinces as
you well know george in south africa
so the question then is well why were
the other seven
where there's quite there's been a great
deal of attitude and in cape town the
taxi drivers
are just killing each other all the time
as they
as as they compete for roots and they
shoot have shootouts etc
so there's a lot of violence but it
didn't spread
which i would say intends to give
some real serious credence
to what rama posed the president
what security spokespeople are saying in
relation
to an actual
political agenda linked through
to zuma but the bottom line of all this
and this is what the government has to
grasp in terms
of the nettle now and that is
in order to clean up yes
if there's evidence that there is a
deep-rooted political subversion
of of this particular grouping
that has been involved put forward the
evidence
charge people arrest them charge them
and put them on trial and nip this in
the bud that way because
these people are speaking about phase
two
of a strategy of going through to
destabilize the country until
zuma's released the thing about the
looting then
is if we see that it's
the zulu kingdom and that it's then an
offshoot into zulu hostels because of
these migrant workers
from from that area in the mines and the
factories
that make johannesburg run they in these
awful hostels
still are which are dominated by
criminals
and traditionalists from zululand and
easily buy into the zuma agenda because
of the whole ethnic aspect but
the fact that the looting is
generated in a mass way obviously isn't
controlled by these particular groups
but there was an influence and it's
shown because as i've said we do see it
functioning in or having burst out in
these
two provinces finally the government
slowly has begun to get on top of it
sanity's returned
a civil society is working people
in communities are cooperating with
police security on the ground
to reinstate order and that kind of
normality
has been returning to south africa
but george one hell of a week
grateful to have had to live through
this
it was it was uh conveyed uh
incredibly powerfully by you uh
it was a nightmare to live through it
was a nightmare frankly to
hear it described in such dystopian
terms um i'll come back to
what i think is the biggest question on
that in a minute but first
other racial aspects beyond the
zulu ethnic issue one
hears maybe propaganda
of white people being singled out for
attack of indian people uh being singled
out for
attack is that accurate and how worrying
is it if it is
well yes it is and it has occurred
put this within the broader context
of the fact that as much
as south africa has advanced and
developed
in these years and we should have done
far far better that
we've found and seen again and i would
say it's linked into socioeconomic
roots um we've seen outbursts over the
years
xenophobia not just out of
the zulu kingdoms kwazulu-natal
province or on the um
the the um area
but also out of cape town out of the
eastern cape
other smaller parts of south africa
where at specific
times they've been out both outbursts of
xenophobia
against so-called foreign nationals
not white and i'll come to whites
but people from as far afield as somalia
who are small traders in this country
pakistanis people from bangladesh
where it's been asianized xenophobia
and africanized in relation to
as i've said somalia and west africans
because
south africa has had its open borders
and there's been this huge influx of
people from abroad
and a lot of that we also have seen is
connected to local traders
who are empty the
competition from business groups
who are able to organize themselves in a
collective way to buy cheaply
and sell cheap goods undercutting them
in the townships
so we've seen that particular aspect
at play we've also seen pockets
of white racism and dreadful attacks
on black people and killings by farmers
for instance
of a black labourer who they've accused
of
stealing a sunflower they are
or cases like this that have littered
the landscape
over these years so the country
has not really come to grips with
the racist cancer
which is still here those seeds from the
past
and we know from britain from france
from germany
from the united states north america
wherever brazil
how hard it is to deal with these
aspects
so in this particular instance
there have been some very ugly scenes um
at townships where you know there's
still the apartheid divisions
where you have indian townships as they
call these are
south africans of asian indian origin
who have been here 150 years and so on
um protecting their particular
communities
against the ravages of this turbulence
and larceny and lootings that we've seen
and at phoenix of specific township
where
it goes actually back there's long
history
because it's an area where there's some
wealth amongst the indian population and
also a lot of poverty
but cheekbone gel surrounded by
black african areas and there have been
problems in the past it's been something
of a hot spot so
in this past week what is surf and
surfacing and we're still not sure
there's talk about 20 young black people
were slaughtered
by these asian defenders of of their
territory
you've also seen in white or
mixed race and white areas similar
defenses of communities in terms of
the so-called you know black peril
this rise of of looting criminality
that they perceive from the indigenous
african
areas so this aspect is worrying
it is it has come to the fore
they've been a very strong attempts
immediately
by government the president's been in
those areas police spokespeople
military presence etc to cauterize that
but south africa continues
because of the fact now go back to the
compromises on the economy
under madiba and not just saying
that was a hundred percent bad we go
back and you've got to be in history we
don't have time
to just go through the analysis of
why the compromises took place in order
to ensure
the political transition to power
but as we well know the trade-offs which
are
actually unacceptable where they that
where the chickens come home to roost
george
and we've seen these chickens coming
home to roost because
we failed to deal with the key
fundamental roots
linked to free market economy and
austerity
the fact that the government from
mandela
have failed to address the crying needs
of the poor in our country and i'm
talking about
80 percent who do not live the protected
comfortable life
of 20 of us i wish we had more time i've
only time for one more
question though we could actually give
over the whole show
to this because the compromises of which
you speak
are of course compromises or conditions
that exist
in almost all countries perhaps with the
exception of of china in
all countries and perhaps even there
but if the proximate cause
is the zuma affair
as i think i infer from the totality of
your remarks
right this and it pains me trust me it
pains me to say this to you in public
uh it's a failure of the anc that we
gave
you gave everything risked your life for
but we all gave
uh our love and our support and our
solidarity
over the best years of our lives it's
heartbreaking
that the anc has been in power all this
time
and the situation is as you have just
described it
exactly that is the proximity and
um you know i don't want to blow my own
bugle
bugle but i challenged zuma
in 2005 within the anc's national
executive committee it's its highest
committee
elected by its annual it's five year
conference
and zuma at that stage had run foul
of in becky another country because of
his connection
with his uh former financial advisor
who had been uh sentenced
in a court of law for financial
corruption and racketeering and
connected to zuma
and zuma had been mentioned by the judge
as being part
of a corrupt relationship but post 1990
and we came back from
exile as you know i and others
i've worked closely with zuma and there
was
a questioning we had about his
narrow nationalism and um
and secrecy and ambitions which were
unhealthy
and there were warnings but the anc
desperately needed
a zulu figurehead
they had very few um at the time and to
neutralize
uh the ifp of butter lazy and
kwazulu-natal where we had
huge violence in the civil war taking
place
so zuma was very fondly
accepted and projected by beniba when
corruption aspects were seen he was
getting into debt
uh all sorts of vultures were now
following him and wanting to
buy and buying things for him filling
his car up with petrol petty stuff etc
madiba arranged for him to get a million
rand
um and you know to basically think
that that was gonna be the way to calm
this guy down it just
fueled his greed and through politics
his greed grew and when becky
stalls him and and and
and actually sacks him as his
deputy president he starts talking about
a political conspiracy
um in a grand way and you know with no
facts and but but this way that beguards
people and
shuts up anybody who's gonna to
contradict
and he's saying no there's a conspiracy
to prevent him
coming to power because he's a zulu
because he's zuma
and i challenged him in the national
executive committee he couldn't answer
he wouldn't answer
the anc allowed him to carry
on along those lines and using that
theory
without challenging the theory and to
some extent
they they still grasp that theory
because it's useful to explain away your
failures
and always then say well we're a
revolutionary liberation movement
and uh this counter-revolution always
dogging us from external and internal
forces and when you have that kind of
situation
you create a hero figure you create
impunity around the man
you don't question this and it led then
to his coming to power as president
and then those awful years um
a dozen years or so in which he ran down
the country it's called the state
capture
issue we know what influences are on
every government from outside and south
africa talked about
that influence of this particular gupta
group
around zuma buying favors and contracts
etc
estate capture of course this is the
influence
of of the classical economic
power basin and relations in south
africa
but it it it is this kind of thing
playing itself out
and then with this divide in the anc
and zuma now under pressure because of
the corruption
um you you had a strong faction
developing within the anc of people who
wanted to get on board that gravy trap
that gravy train that bandwagon who got
promotion who got position
above their abilities um and and then
this running down of of the state
structures that then took place
because it's the state structures in
their budget that these people basically
focus
on as frontiers and they're stripping
the state
because they can't really compete with a
traditional
economic power relation and control of
the country
and that's where the state had come in
for this
absolute um
theft that has taken place and the
weakening of the state
so the anc became rotten
and there's that struggle that you're
referring to
and that that political politicized
agenda
within police and intelligence and so on
that so affected the situation um
in in the country so this is at the door
of the anc
it's not the anc that we once knew
they pretend they are and the big
question for ramaposa
is if in fact there's going to be a
renewal
in the anc and there's it's got a
movement in relation to that within the
anc
people who want to save it a lot of
people who are honest and decent
um and if he's going to win that of
course
he's got to rid himself of the zuma
grouping
which is underway i believe their shelf
life
is is is up and zuma's shelf life is up
he doesn't have the patronage power of
buying
people and giving favors etc so i think
that's on the way
and that's why they're so desperate at
the moment with the
game this is absolutely dangerous
sinister game that they're playing but
final point can ramaposa
do and i'm not now going to fly a red
flag
of direct socialism you're a socialist
i'm a socialist i'll die a socialist
with you
george and we know that's the really the
the only way to save this benighted
world
from haiti to india
from the philippines to britain and
all over latin america etc
but we don't have the united
states
of the 18 1980s of even 1994
they weak as has happened elsewhere in
the world for the reasons
of neo-liberal rundown of their
industries etc
can ramaposa therefore and i'm
old-fashioned
and i believe in history like you do
it's got the lessons for us
but i'll use the words fdr franklin
delano roosevelt
i'm not they're going to say he's the
angel that is projected as
by that way of buying spending
going against austerity going for new
deal
job creation um and and
infrastructure building giving people
jobs
turning the wicked corner that south
africa became
part of having the guts and the courage
again
to reinstate the liberation morality and
ethic
that we built up over all those years of
struggle
for international solidarity anc
was social democratic but at least
that kind of recipe which in this day
and age
needs inordinate power
we see venezuela we see cuba
of course with china it is so much
different because of the power that they
have
but it's that kind of response that i'm
talking about that south africa urgently
needs to get out of this deep deep hole
not only that zuma has has dug
but that we unfortunately have over seen
since 1994. finally we
we both know although not everyone you
only people of a certain age know
the debt that free south africa owed to
cuba we now see
an obvious regime change
operation being mounted it may have
misfired
certainly seems to have run out of steam
very quickly
uh what's your take
on what they're trying to do in cuba and
what's your
analysis of its chances of
succeeding
let me respond to that first it's
got no hope of succeeding and why
because this cuban revolution
is people based as we well know
and everything that they've done since
the cuban revolution of
1959 has been
to develop their
economy their health services their
education
programs to their military power
their street committees
in order to protect a revolution
in order to advance the people's
living conditions and we know
how that has taken place and the
enormous success and achievements
so much so that cuba's international
solidarity
stemmed from that and embraced
so many schools and schools of countries
including countries like angola
south africa namibia zimbabwe
mozambique in relation to the liberation
struggle against racism
against the cia and
and helped as castro pointed out about
the battle of peter guanavala in africa
in angola which vanquished the south
african forces
that the history of africa would have to
be written as before and after quite
quina vale etc
but yes there's the squires we see in
the streets we visited
cuba i was taken to areas from where
dissatisfied people um
have emerged and have emerged in the
past because it's not the first
time we see protest and why
it's precisely because of the wickedness
of american sanctions and the way that
is
applied in the most criminal way the
blockade and
embargo of cuba against not just the
cuban people
but against the voting at the u.n
general council
where only two countries voted against
the lifting of the embargo
and that was the united states and his
damn friend the criminal regime's
honest regime of israel just the other
day so
of course what we're seeing is what
we've seen fermented
all over the world and you're referring
earlier you made reference to
yugoslavia the role of nato there
the role of nato throughout europe these
color revolutions
etc i'm not saying the cubans don't say
that they made no errors but any
weaknesses have emanated
from this insidious vicious disgraceful
criminal blockade and sanctions of the
usa
and it's being dealt with and sometimes
we've seen some scenes of people being
roughed up and
taken off and plotted off to prison
they're breaking the law if that is the
case
they've been dealt with that way so it's
it's not something
that that that we'd be happy about it's
something that we see
as the kind of threat of the american
empire
reinforced by nato reinforced by the
united kingdom
to roll back the tide that you and i
lived through george and we're lucky to
be alive today but i'm talking about
the great anti-colonial struggles
post the second world war which changed
the war
which saw the downfall of colonialism of
the empires of europe
britain and france germany and so on
portugal
spain uh belgium and and and
and then the united states and what have
we been
seeing occurring and whether it's trump
whether it's
biden it's american foreign policy it's
what's ripped apart
the middle east from afghanistan through
to palestine
syria through to iraq the areas that
you've done
such good work in and continue to but
it's
it's that attempt we living at a time
where on the one hand socialism broke
down in so many countries
we have vietnam and cuba and china at
least outstanding
um and we we we've seen
the ravages then under the neocolonial
empires of the world today but it is an
american decline that can still
do so much harm and i think and i would
still
say and believe they come up against the
hard
rock of the cuban revolution
which will survive i absolutely believe
that
and this is why the work you do the work
we do on palestine and again palestine
is such a victim of neo-liberal
corruption
in relation to the palestine authority
we've got to
and hope to see a whole change in the
political dynamic and leadership of the
palestinian people they've been
wonderful things
as we know that have been happening in
recent times
the american agenda this is quite uh a
tour de force
i think it will become a collector's
item
but i need to take a break for the news
they're shouting at me
thank you very much ronnie castro your
excellency
a great great pleasure an honor to
interview you this evening let's go
quickly i'm late
to the news with jamie law
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news the british prime
minister and chancellor will now
self-isolate
after contact with health secretary
sajid javid who tested positive for
coronavirus
the u-turn comes just hours after they
said they would take part in a pilot
scheme
involving daily testing instead of
self-isolation
opposition parties had said it suggested
there was one rule for them
and another for the rest of us downing
street said boris johnson will conduct
meetings remotely at his country
residents checkers
chancellor rissy sunak said on twitter
whilst the test and trace pilot is
fairly restrictive
allowing only essential government
business i recognize that even the sense
that the rules aren't the same for
everyone
is wrong labour leader sakir stamis said
the prime minister and chancellor had
been busted yet again for thinking the
rules that we are all
following don't apply to them
supermarkets have warned that they will
have to cut opening hours or even
shut shops if the number of workers
forced to self-isolate continues to rise
marks and spencer said the number of
workers being notified by the nhs app is
rising exponentially
and it may have to reduce hours if there
are shortages
another leading supermarket said it
could lead to massive disruption
of food supplies quote and there's a
risk that there won't be sufficient
staff to open
shops last week over 500 000 alerts were
sent to users
of the nhs test and trace app in england
and wales for the week
to the 7th of july a rise of 46
on the previous week from the 16th of
august people who have been fully
vaccinated will not have to
self-isolated if they are pinged by the
nhs app
when they have come into contact with
someone who has tested positive for
covid
however fully vaccinated travellers
returning to scotland from france
will still have to quarantine despite
rules changing
from monday adults who have been double
jabbed in the uk arriving from ambulance
countries will not need to isolate for
10 days
but the scottish government said those
returning from france would still have
to isolate this is because of concerns
that vaccines may not work as well
against the beta variant the beta
variant accounts for about 10 of new
infections in france but
that includes the indian ocean
territories of reunion
and mayotay where the variant is near
universal the more infectious delta
variant first identified in india
accounts for almost
all new cases in the uk under the new
rules those coming back to scotland from
france will need to stay in their own
accommodation
and take a test on the second and eighth
day of their isolation period
even if they've had both doses of the
vaccine
eight members of team gb have been
forced into isolation after coming into
contact with a covert case on their
flight to the tokyo
olympics the six athletes and two
members of staff tested negative before
departure
and upon arrival in japan but have since
been identified
as a close contact of an infected person
who shared their journey on thursday
that person is not a member of team gb
the british olympic association
said german chancellor angela merkel has
expressed shock at what she described as
surreal destruction
caused by last week's flooding merkel
visited affected areas of western
germany on sunday talking to survivors
and emergency workers
at least 184 people in belgium and
germany are now known to have died in
the floods heavy rain is continuing to
wreak havoc with attention now shifting
to parts of
austria and southern germany emergency
crews rescued people from homes in the
austrian region of salzburg
where flood waters submerged the streets
of one town the capital vienna
saw more rainfall in an hour on saturday
night than in the previous seven weeks
in western germany authorities said
steinbeck till dam
southwest of bonn remained at risk of
breaching after residents were evacuated
from homes downstream
european leaders have blamed climate
change for the floods which have also
affected switzerland
luxembourg and the netherlands the widow
of haiti's assassinated president has
returned to the caribbean nation after
being
treated in florida for wounds suffered
in the attack
martine moisey was seen wearing an arm
sling and a bulletproof vest after
arriving by plane
at port-au-prince airport yesterday her
husband juvenile moisee was killed by
assassins
in their home on the 7th of july the u.s
singer britney spears has said she will
not perform again whilst her father
retains control over her career
as part of a conservative ship set up in
2008. the singer's message is the latest
in a series of emotional public comments
about the arrangement
that controls her personal and financial
affairs
quote this conservative ship killed my
dreams she said in a lengthy post on
instagram
so all i have is hope the conservative
ship was put in place after her father
jamie spears
petitioned a court for legal authority
over the pop star's life amid concerns
about her mental health
brittany added quote i'm not going to be
performing to any stages anytime soon
with my dad handling what i wear say do
or think
she has not appeared in public since
2018.
and finally kazunori takashima traveled
the world to support japan at
every olympic games for the past 15
years so
it was a dream to see the event in his
home city of tokyo
he spent almost 40 thousand dollars on
197 tickets for him and friends but when
a ban on spectators was announced last
week due to covert 19
that dream died quote it took an
unbelievable amount of time
effort and passion takashima said but i
was so passionate about the olympics
that even though
it was very difficult and challenging i
enjoyed the process of buying the
tickets
the 45 year old businessman worked out
that if he watched all the events he had
booked
he would have broken the guinness world
record for attendance
at the olympic games quote all i have
now is sadness
and every time i look at the tickets i
cry takashima said i am just
sad he will however get a refund for
those tickets but because of covid
only members of the media and selected
dignitaries will be allowed to watch the
events this year's games which open
on friday delayed from summer 2020 due
to the coronavirus pandemic
and that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm joey lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
will you be wearing a face covering next
week that's in britain of course
a yes 32 percent b no
52 c when asked
to 16 a lot of votes
but you've still got uh i think uh 45 or
15 minutes still to vote on my twitter
feed we've spoken about south africa
we've spoken about cuba we can't speak
about cuba without speaking about haiti
because hey
they're next door neighbors and the best
man
i have yet met to speak about haiti
is an editor of haiti liberty
which as the name suggests does its best
to
foster freedom in haiti which has been a
very
very difficult wicket for a very very
long time
his name is kim ives i hear that the
line is a little unsteady
but i'm very much hoping to see him now
kim
welcome to the mother of all talk shows
i do hope we can hear each other
the vision's not as important uh being
i've done certain asia i sometimes
wish it was only my voice that was on
the screen
but that's not of course something that
affects you
what does affect you is the fact that
haiti
just got its president murdered
by persons as yet unknown although i'm
willing to bet
you've got some pretty hot theories
let's start with the killing
of the president tell us what you know
if you would
well what we're pretty sure we know
george is that
uh colombian mercenaries machine gunned
him at close range
after shooting his wife martine this is
what she told a close friend
who told us that story uh
she was struck by bullets in the arm and
two in the leg and uh
he feigned to be dead
and then the mercenary
shot movie close range
killing him mutilating his body removing
his left eye
breaking bones and the
next day after we published our report
on wednesday
on saturday one of the mercenaries
being interrogated broke down and in
tears said that yes there was a
team of seven within the 26
that have been uh captured
which did this plot so it appears there
was a plot within a plot
where there were seven men uh
tasked with machine gunning the
president to death
they did so the other 19 may have well
been dupes
uh they thought they were bodyguards for
somebody important
which is why some of the uh discordant
reports come out with
saying the family there to guard
somebody but
uh one of them broke down and said yes
we indeed we indeed did
shoot the president to death and have we
any idea of the provenance of this
plot uh no we don't
my working hypothesis our working
hypothesis and
liberte is that it was the sector of the
bourgeoisie
which is very rich which uh paid for it
and
uh commissioned it and this is in
particular
uh two families the boulos family or i
should say reginald boulos
who is a sort of businessman now turned
uh presidential candidate and another
family called
vorb uh the entire vorp family is a
little like the chamorro family and um
nicaragua they're all over the map but
dimitri vorb
ended up becoming a fierce opponent of
zognil
uh after george now uh that
he wasn't going to pay the board's
sweetheart deal
uh on electricity he has a uh energy
production company which was supporting
the grid
after the petrocaribe deal fell through
in 2018
jonelle came to him and said listen dude
i can't tell you what you want
and the guy went over to trying to
unseat
jovenel so uh we're pretty sure that the
providence is from this sector
uh they seem to have the motive they
have the means
and uh one thing for sure too we have to
keep in mind is that
for us it's impossible that the u.s
embassy which has uh uh antennas all
over its roof it's the fourth largest
embassy in the world
for the u.s uh and they follow all the
cell phone traffic all the internet
traffic
and it's impossible that they could not
have had a notion
about this they performed they prevail
2000 about a plot against him they
foiled it at that time
why didn't they inform jovenel about
this one we don't know but this suggests
they might have
at the very least had a wink and a nod
with respect to the operation
such as the dysfunctionality
quite often but certainly now in haiti
what are the prospects of the killers of
the president
being brought to justice very slim
very slim they have a saying in haiti
the inquiry is ongoing and this is often
how most inquiries end
ongoing uh these people if it is indeed
the sector of the bourgeoisie they're
very powerful powerful somebody like
uh reginald boulos can't even really be
considered haitian he's really part of
the transnational bourgeoisie
he has holdings everywhere in the states
in
uh neighboring dominican republic in
haiti of course
and uh he was in fact born an american
citizen he
he uh reclaimed some of his patient
nationality back when he was 18. so this
is a very powerful man
and the odds that in haiti's
weakened debilitated state and judicial
system
they would be able to find him uh
guilty much less arrest him and it
should be said that juvenile mourinho's
had a turn out against against uh
reginald boulos before he was killed
so to what extent that last warrant and
what was
we are told in an imminent seizing
of reginald facilities in haiti
may very well have been the trigger for
the assassination now the last time we
spoke you described uh a quite
fascinating phenomenon which is
a massive lumpen
proletarian uh mass
in the capital puerto prance usually
referred to as gangs
although gangs doesn't quite do it and
gang leaders although gang leaders
doesn't
quite do it as you described it to me
before
it struck me that these were
political forces on the ground in haiti
there are potentially uh powerful
players
is that how you see it absolutely
uh what we see coming out of the shanty
towns
of port-au-prince is
i could say a self-aware movement in the
long control level
where they have suddenly realized their
power because they have been armed
by the bourgeoisie to carry out its
political struggles
to fight the battles on the field to be
the cannon fodder
of the bourgeoisies battles and even of
the empire's battles
they suddenly have become aware that
they are being used
that they are sending the blood of their
brothers
usually facing them and so that is the
message
indeed of this leader who has emerged
the charismatic leader i can even say
who is a great admirer is a great
admirer of john bertrand aristide
a certain jimmy cherisier known as
barbecue
who has said we have to stop fighting
among each other
and we have to turn the guns which the
bourgeoisie have
given us to fight among each other we
have to turn it on them
and carry out a revolution to get rid of
this stinking
rotten system and he has galvanized
uh much of the port-au-prince prince
underclass
into a political force and i think this
was the primary force george
that made boulos panic because he said
in the week before
the assassination of jovano moise we are
going to seize your grocery stores
your gas stations your
porch your uh banks and we are going to
take what is ours and this is where
uh the bourgeoisie really panicked they
saw an existential
threat coming from this bourgeoisie from
this
lump and proletariat and they need to
stamp it out they may have hoped that
they could get a strong leader one that
was faithful to them
as they thought juvenile movies was
going to be but trophy
maui's turned out to be an imperfect
puppet he rebelled on them
they wanted to get one in but more than
that i think they
hoped to provoke a foreign military
intervention a u.s
military and they are in fact simply
extension of the usa
they represent the interests of u.s
corporations in haiti
mostly uh companies who are using
haitian cheap labor five bucks a day
to make their a lot electronics and
clothing and so
here you have essentially the allies of
the empire
calling on the empire to intervene
through carrying out this heinous act
of machine gunning uh president as
embattled and as
questionably legitimate as he was so
uh this is the situation that we see and
we're pretty sure the facts are gonna
bear us out
in haiti now we're investigating this in
many areas i can't give all the details
but
uh we are hot on the trail
we think of uh well uh we'll definitely
we'll definitely have to have you back
last question though
if the u.s were to physically intervene
the barbecue and his men might make it
hot for them
they could they could you hope to
remember a century ago
george there was a movement called the
cacos they were
they were bandits they were considered
the gangs of the day back then
and they were galvanized into a fighting
force into
one of history's great guerrilla forces
by a fellow called
charlemagne perrault and they fought the
marines
for three or four years before the
marines uh one marine wearing blackface
infiltrated the camp and shot shauna
maymar
for out through the heart it didn't end
the movement his one of his lieutenants
benoit atroville continued the struggle
for a few more
years but eventually the marines
deployed the forces to uh suppress
and defeat the movement and um
but could uh this jimmy share is here
become another charlemagne
history will tell but uh i think there
are many indications that he has that
potential
kim hives stay safe and we need to talk
again thank you very much for joining us
on the mother of
all talk shows kim ives in
haiti how is the uh how is this going
will
you be wearing a face covering next week
yes 32
no 52 c when asked to
16 percent plenty of votes coming in
don't forget you can vote right up until
the hour
now rachel blevins our uh
regular star from the united states
joins us again now to talk about
all things americana but starting rachel
if i may with the extraordinary
i don't know if it was a blunder or it
was scripted
but the extraordinary statement made by
president biden
about the social media companies
effectively well not effectively
actually
accusing them of killing people and
demanding
a total censorship of the
airwaves and the irony of that coming on
the same day
he was condemning cuba for a lack of
internet freedom
um go tell us how
did this happen what does this mean
you know it's always ironic and what's
even more ironic
perhaps is this new fight that's coming
out between
facebook and the white house they're
going back and forth
on who they are accusing of being able
to combat what they refer to as
misinformation
and what's interesting is that right
before we heard that statement from
biden we also heard from press secretary
jenn saki
openly saying that the white house is
telling facebook who to censor on their
platform
now think about that in context of just
any other thing that they could possibly
talk about what the white house refers
to as misinformation
one that could mean literally anything
two we're hearing from the white house
that is admitting
that they are the ones working with
facebook the surgeon general is telling
facebook
who to block what post to take down
which post to promote
on different people's timelines and i
mean if we were to put that in the
context of anything else
whether it was the white house trying to
save sell the american people a war
against another country
and they were to come in and tell
facebook this is who can and cannot
speak on your platform
i mean the precedent that this sets is
incredibly terrifying
all the way around and yet they're up
there talking about it at the white
house this is not some whistleblower
report that came out
that we're now referencing this is being
openly talked about as if it's
completely normal
yes and and i saw a president biden
uh say it in not as many words and not
as eloquently but that's what he
said and this in the context
of the standard us and british
trope that other countries don't have
freedom of speech that their governments
tell the media what they can and cannot
say but we've this has got form
doesn't it because i was looking again
the other day
at the uh hunter biden story
and the laptop uh which we now know for
certain
was his laptop he handed it in to the
repair
shop it's his signature on the receipt
and yet that story about what was on
that laptop
and all the dirty dealings of all kinds
that it revealed was ruthlessly
suppressed
by twitter by facebook by the entire
social media world
in order to ensure that joe biden became
the president
the very man who is now calling them
killers yeah you know it's interesting
that you bring up the argument of free
speech because i think a lot of times
whenever we talk about social media
censorship which
for example i had my facebook page taken
down my facebook
a few years ago lost 70 000 followers
and they gave me no excuse for it
whatsoever they just said oh well you
violated our policies
well when i told a lot of people about
that when i talked about it
a response that i got often was well
facebook is a private company they don't
owe you the freedom of speech they can
take your page down if they want to
well now we're hearing that you have the
government the white house telling
facebook what can and cannot be said
so that kind of takes away from that
argument does it that adds another
element there of wondering exactly what
is motivating those decisions
and i think a lot of times whenever it
comes to something and it's a consensus
where
all of the mainstream media says well it
must be true because the white house
says that it's true and now that's
applying to social media
well that sets an even greater
terrifying precedent because
it sets this age where before it used to
be
that you would hear something talked
about on cnn or fox news and then you
would go to social media to sound off on
it
well now if you're not allowed to talk
on social media because they've
automatically labeled it as
misinformation
i mean that just go there there's no way
in which that can keep
us safer and there's no way in which
that can actually help
the free flow of information because
you're deciding what can and cannot be
censored
based solely not on what is true and is
not true
but based on what the white house says
is okay to be put
out there this week or next week or
whenever it comes to their timeline
is is zuckerberg going to roll over and
cry
uncle at this or is he going to fight it
oh no he's going to go right along with
it because right now what congress has
done for the last few years
is they've sat around and they've said
big tech has too much power and they
pointed out all of the ways
that facebook and twitter and google are
just impossible to take down
well those tech giants know that
congress can make their lives a living
hell when it comes to fines when it
comes to trying to break up their
companies
so what they're doing is they're trying
to stay on good terms with congress and
that's why
you see people like mark zuckerberg
going along with this
because he doesn't want to be hit with
the claims that he was hit with back in
2016.
whatever you had all of the claims of
russia gave well it was blamed on
facebook saying
oh well facebook allowed these so-called
conspiracy theories to go they allowed
all of this to happen so now it's
facebook's fault that donald trump is in
the white house
so that's put facebook in this place
where they're saying okay okay we'll
play along with whatever it is that the
white house wants we'll play along
with going along with these claims that
we are combating misinformation on their
behalf
just as long as they don't turn around
and try to go after
us and kind of leave us alone and let us
live a little bit and continue to become
even more powerful
now the political and media class got
terribly excited
last weekend uh what they thought hoped
planned maybe uh would be uh
a ukrainian-style color revolution
uh breaking out in cuba they're not so
uh buoyant or rebelliant this weekend
because the very small protests against
the cuban government uh contrast
with the vast demonstrations of support
for the cuban state that have happened
since
but there's a lot of uh demonstrating
going on
in florida in california and
elsewhere um cuba says the u.s
planned and scripted this whole thing uh
how does that look to you from there
well i would say it wouldn't be the
first time they planned and scripted
something like that certainly not with
cuba and
i think that this is a case where with
president biden himself i mean when he
was on the campaign trail
he talked about how horrible it was that
president trump took steps to undo
the terms of trying to possibly
normalize relations with cuba that obama
put in place
biden wasn't a fan of that when he was
on the campaign trail then all of a
sudden he gets into office and now he's
saying oh no sorry we can't
take steps back we can't you know remove
any of this blockade on cuba
and it's notable that you're seeing a
lot of people speaking up now
and seeing of course they're not getting
media coverage whenever they're out
speaking out about just
how cruel and criminal the united states
treatment of cuba has been
and on top of that i mean we look back
to 2017
and we are reminded of those jfk
assassination files that were released
which
literally showed that the cia was openly
plotting
multiple attacks to try to spark a war
with cuba because they knew
that the american people didn't want it
they knew that it was not favorable
and yet some of the attacks that they
were discussing were either attacking an
american ship off of guantanamo bay and
blaming it on cuba to try to spark a war
or they were also talking about possibly
attacking a ship of cuban refugees and
then blaming it on rebels i mean these
were discussions that were being had
and approved at the time we're only just
learning about this
you know back a few years ago whenever
those files were finally released
after several decades and it's important
to remember that this is our history
this is the united states government's
history
what they were okay with talking about
and that's something that needs to
come back to center stage now especially
when you have a vitamin administration
that is making some of the statements
that they are making when it comes to
cuba today
has trump been in or rather out any news
from him rachel
you know not much he's seen we've seen a
few more speeches from him there's a lot
of talk that he's going to run in 2024
and he's kind of holding back on making
that official announcement
saying that he knows what he's going to
do but he hasn't quite put it out there
yet
we know that you know he's filed
lawsuits he's joined in class action
lawsuits rather
against some of the big tech companies
and one of the most interesting things
that has come out of those lawsuits is
the fact
that he refers to facebook and twitter
as
state actors and i think that's a really
notable thing especially at a time
when we're talking about the white house
openly saying that it's colluding
with facebook when it comes to the
content that is on their platform well a
term like state actors
actually goes a long way when it comes
to what facebook's doing right now
and finally we we i saw a reference to
some kind of victory for trump in the
uh election counting uh
the the investigation into electoral
fraud
in arizona uh it seemed to suggest that
trump
did after all win arizona although he
was cheated
out of it on the night can you enlighten
us on that
you know i've seen back and forth on
that as to the results and it's kind of
one of those things where each source
has something different to say so i
don't know that i can comment on that
exactly but i do think it lends to
exactly what a lot of what we've heard
from trump which is continuing to look
back to the 2020 election
and continuing to use that as his
reference at a time
when a lot of americans are saying hey
it's 2021 we're moving on how long
is this going to keep coming back up and
keep coming back around and i think it's
going to take
a number of states having results like
that in a number of states saying
hey these irregularities were similar to
what trump said in order for there to
really be momentum there
um but i'm sure we will hear more and
more from him as the months go away
indeed and hopefully from you rachel
blevins thank you for joining us
on the mother of all talk shows now if
you're
in the united kingdom you can call us
completely free
on
five double 081-965522 that's oh eight
one
nine six double five double two or if
you're in the united states where it's
equally free it's plus one
eight four four nine four four double
three
double four that's plus one nine uh
sorry
plus one eight four four nine four
four double three double four
and you can email us at on air
moats dot tv let's get some phone calls
in
jim in fort worth go ahead jim
no no fort collins george okay
thank you for that correction go ahead
jim no problem
okay uh on cuba the mayor of
miami was interviewed on fox news this
week
and um he gave the usual spiel
but the fox uh news presenter
asked them to wait a minute yeah cuba
has these problems but
you know what about the sanctions that
the u.s is putting on them
now you know they usually don't do that
in the united states no
challenge him like that and not on fox
either
and so he babbled away about oh the
people don't want that
was he the one who who called on the
united states to bomb
cuba yeah it's going on like that
but this is the thing that got me um
some of the people on the
jacobin this guy
has buildings in his city that are
falling down
or being abandoned
they were built by the free enterprise
system you know
he's talking about cuba being a failed
state
unbelievable they're in good form here
george
you're a gentleman always a pleasure to
hear from you let's go to germany
and talk with julian go ahead julian
hello george this is julian from germany
welcome
i i wanted to talk about like our
elections in germany they're
coming up right in september okay and uh
it's about
climate change uh climate change uh
excuse my bad english but um
i have the feeling like um they are
using like globalist um
propaganda like to win some elections
like
to like keep the cdu
our christian democratic party in in
power and it's
um we are right now experience in
experiencing
major floodings in in the western part
of germany
and um our government and the media
they they already put it on on climate
change
but um if you look closer
it's obvious that they have done nothing
like to prevent damage from
like heavy rainfall which was predicted
like for years now
and uh they are there instead they are
talking about
hydrogen fuels and electric cars and
we don't even have like the fuel to run
them with green energy
until like 2030 or 2040 or later
so like all of this
has been started like 20 years ago or
three
30 years ago like al gore we all
remember like
the elections in the united states with
al gore
it was all about zero two already like
when merkel
our chancellor when she started it's
like 16 years now
that she has been our chancellor she was
she starred as our minister of
environment
and she was already back then she was
like
pushing forward like green energy and
co2
reduction and uh it's it's like it feels
like a joke
because it's it's all coming up again
it's the
the very old propaganda it's all coming
up again and
it has like it has like a true side in
it and
i think like all countries on earth they
would like support a goal of
like have a better sustainable life on
earth
but it's not about this in my opinion so
like
20 years ago already they they started
to
like fight against nuclear power the
green party they were against nuclear
power they they wanted to stop coal and
and now we have like
when it happened in fukushima in japan
there was a big
big big earthquake and in germany we
don't have earthquakes we don't have
volcanoes
we have like we can have like secure
nuclear power
and and now it's back it should be back
on the table at least
well uh yeah i mean we don't have time
to debate nuclear power but i'm with you
on that one um we don't have time
actually
and i don't have the expertise to debate
the
german elections we're relying on you uh
to give us a prediction here julian
uh mrs merkel is going finally
we don't yet know i think who our
successor
in the cdu will be but whoever it is it
would seem likely they will prevail
because
the other parties have fallen away the
spd the labour equivalent uh
the far right
if afb is it
the afd alliance for deutschland uh
they they've all fallen away so it looks
like whoever
merkel's party picks will be the new
chancellor is that
how you how you see it i think you're
right george
i think like um the our our our
chancellor party
like the cdu they are like establishing
um
let's say like the environment to be to
be voted again
in power and it's happening again and
this this time they will like
not uh be in a coalition with like the
social democrats without failing that
not just in the uk
they are failing in germany too so like
uh they will be in
in a coalition with a green party and
this uh
basically their goal so like maybe you
know our southern
uh uh president like uh soda markus
and and and this guy he is like just
copying
he's just copying the narrative of the
green parties
and it's it's just because the globalist
again is telling him to do so
to just to win the elections
fascinating julian you we need to uh
schedule a proper discussion on the
german elections i hope you'll
contribute to it thank you very much
indeed
uh for that uh call now on this day
in 2003 missing government scientist
and weapons inspector dr david
kelly was found dead what
had he revealed to a bbc reporter
about a government dossier a that it was
sexed up
b that iraq had weapons of mass
destruction
or c alistair campbell wrote it
answer after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
tom says after independence we could
choose the government we want
tom could you not have called me
and argued that nonsense
couldn't you what's wrong with you man
you've had the vaccine go ahead i went
when i came out i went into a box of
stamps and started doing a jig
and an old fella said hey haven't you
just done that right so even said i even
said to his wife
come on love you better get me
so you're full of life and ben says
could scotland actually do
better autonomously like i want
california to secede
but i think we'd thrive if not broadened
by the rest of the us
how very revealing of you ben oh
utterly revealing of you and philip says
how any labor or tory supporter
has the nerve to say the snp are corrupt
is beyond me why do you people not have
the guts to call
up instead of cowering behind
one single name on social media
there's a lot of people in bradford who
won't be taking this uh
antivirus due to religious backgrounds
simon what do you mean by
religious grounds religious grounds i
mean many muslims for example have
issues with regards to this uh vaccine
certainly
what issues well for example pork what
does pork have to do with this vaccine
you're you're um you're you're kind of
again you're you're clouding the issue
here this religious i'm not clouding the
issue you said
poor thank you you said pork
some
be quiet for a moment please no i won't
it's just
this is dangerous reckless
ignorant and potentially
fatal nonsense get out of my sight
and don't come back
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
now of course dr david kelly revealed
that the government's dossier
on weapons of mass destruction in iraq
had been
quote unquote sexed up a subject to
which we shall return
with the right honourable norman baker
in the final
hour norman of course is uh an executive
director
of executive producer rather of my film
killing kelly which was launched had its
premiere
in london last night meanwhile
we're joined by the irrepressible
rising ever rising television and radio
star
mr patrick christie's patrick hello
welcome
back uh to the show speaking of tv
what on earth has happened at gb
news well it's been an interesting week
hasn't seen guitar hari who was
guest presenting a show there decided
that at one point she was going to take
the knee and outline his views on as you
do when you're presenting a tv
radio show next to a black presenter who
disagrees with it of course but you know
a little bit of virtue signaling never
really want any harm apart from him
because he has harmed him
it's cost him his job now in response a
lot of the gb news viewers decided that
they didn't want to view it
anymore and they recorded zero views for
several of their shows in the wake of
this
they then released a statement saying
well well we're essentially quite sorry
about it
it goes against our company policy but
we stand against racism et cetera
quite a confusing statement really yeah
it was hard to see which part of their
policy
went against and also rather shot the
fox of their
whole if you'll forgive the pan fox uh
their whole shtick which was that they
believed in
freedom of speech and against the cancer
culture and this is
how it's been cancelled being cancelled
now this is it's amazing isn't it really
and that's
really the main issue i think for gp
news because you know it's about council
culture it is about the fact that you're
supposed to be a bastard of free speech
on both sides and
this is what we've been crying out for
in the media isn't it and then yeah
someone does something like that which
is not really against any ofcom
guidelines and
i would be surprised if it was indeed
against gbn's actual company policy
um and they they cancel him but they are
i think
i i i do wonder if it's a sign of maybe
them them getting quite concerned about
where they're at i know that there were
a few technical issues at the start as
one would expect of course
andrew neal has vacated the premises for
a period of time hasn't he which is
again
uh quite telling i think then i think on
top of that then
they maybe saw that their viewing
figures were dipping i mean they were
out performed one time by
the welsh version of a kids cartoon
program paw patrol
sorry there you go which is the top show
well yeah
certainly more of a top show than gb
news but that said
that's that gb news needs to be given
time is creating jobs people in the
media i think by and large
you cannot expect a new startup to get
everything right all the time and i know
that they've got big plans to
to really kick on again nigel france
just got a show on there of course he
does bring you ratings the matter of
fact so
yeah look i would expect them to to go
again as it were i know they've made a
couple of hirings in the last
few days um and so so yeah i think
they're going to rebrand i think they've
lost
of course some of their top executives
who've walked over a variety of issues
either the
the taking of the knee issue or the
generally
very poor technical quality of the show
uh i can't speak for andrew neal
of course but i'd be surprised if he was
not embarrassed
by the poor technical quality that he
was
associated with his his face was on the
tin
but i'm not sure that he actually called
all that many of the shots
yeah well that's it yeah so a couple of
things though john mccondrew of course
who was one of the the major directors
a programming director there and he had
a big role to play in attracting a loss
of the star names that they got
initially had a big role to play
in setting up their output and indeed
setting up their running orders
uh and it was very influential
influential figure there he stepped down
in the wake of the taking the knee issue
uh and then obviously as we've said
there on junile there's gone there is an
argument with engineer whilst i can
fully appreciate that amount of his
stature and his standing and only
a history as it were equality would not
want to be associated with anything that
was
anything other than tip top and i get
that absolutely he is chairman and i
think in a ratings game he was one of
the main people to bring either ratings
and there is a case to say that maybe he
should have grown and beared it for a
while
but you know obviously he's he's been
around he said he's not going to take
lessons for anyone is he's not going to
do it
these star names that you uh talk about
of course were largely uh b-list star
names but
uh yeah i mean some of them were known
people calling brazier
gave up a good job at sky but this
uh turn that they appear to be making
with the appointment of nigel farage
to a nightly show monday to thursday
uh seems to be a turn towards culture
war
type tv but how they going to square
that
with the state regulator ofcom you and i
both know
uh ofcom if it wants to and doesn't
always want to but
when it wants to it can wreak havoc
in off-commable media uh
for not uh not achieving balance in
their shows
yeah i've come i've got involved with gb
news a couple of times already there was
one on the very first opening night
actually dan watson was speaking about
um i think with the lockdown of course
and he was forced to offcom
he got oh we got to say go away it was
proven to have nothing done nothing
wrong and
uh and then the chief of offcom as well
this is when everyone was talking about
cancelling gp news cancelling the
adverts you know
barricading them away et cetera and well
actually what happened there was
obviously
one of the chiefs ofcon just came out
and said actually you know what i've
seen nothing so far at gb news
uh that would warrant me having any kind
of concerns whatsoever
you would imagine that they would
counter nigel farage with something or
potentially within that show they feel
as though they can give strong opinion
but be able to find a way of giving
balance as well really
so yeah they could always harm me but i
don't think they can afford me
uh the uh the uh other issue
uh that you just touched on there that's
raging now
yeah is the uh coveted uh
freedom day the ping that told
for the prime minister and the
chancellor
who are not going to be able to enjoy
their own freedom day
because they're going to be locked up at
home but they handled that
so badly the tory government oh
absolutely awful yeah it was it was it
was a lesson in in how not to handle a
situation like that
yes i think the sadji javid of course is
despite the fact that he's been double
jabbed
as we understand it has got coronavirus
clearly then boris johnson and russia
soon after the implications that they've
been in close proximity with the sag
and so therefore they were personalized
they got ping now
um yeah they they decided to say that
they were part of a new pilot scheme it
took them just two and a half hours to
u-turn
on this i think it was insulting because
first and foremost he tried to claim
actually that the pilot scheme was
random a random generator well that's
interesting because several members of
the cabinet have found their way into it
including the prime minister so for a
random generator
he's been hovering quite quite quite
outdoors yeah yeah
exactly yeah um they also then said that
their voice doesn't release a statement
saying well it's true that we
we briefly considered uh not
self-isolating to the point where you
put a press release out about it you
sent poor old robert generic
only to come off air and almost
immediately they go sorry rob mate yeah
we've gone back on that so so that's
probably
at least i know at least they know that
uh they owe rob one and but what he did
actually was take the heat off uh one
john berker the dumpy despot was back in
the news today
because it's emerged that he has been
taking his pension at the age of 58 not
35 grand a year which he said he
wouldn't do and then
he blamed his wife sally for making him
do it so that shows what kind of
individual he is
and boris johnson because boris
apparently it's just such a visible chap
that nothing matters anymore
well that leads me to we've got someone
wants to talk to us on the line but
before we
turn to victor in greenwich
um such is the state of discombobulation
at the top of the government and
such is the impecunious situation
that boris johnson finds himself in with
alimony
almost without number he certainly can't
count it
because we don't know how many he's had
you wouldn't be that surprised if boris
walked would you
it's an interesting one really isn't it
because i think obviously you tend to
make all your money after you've
finished being prime minister don't you
i suppose um
well i think boris clearly has got a lot
yeah but the ex-wives won't wait
no they won't no they won't uh and those
bills are stacking up though and i don't
get the impression that he's been
particularly careful with his money over
the years as well so there's
there's that what he seems to have a
habit of doing at the moment is getting
a cabal of very wealthy individuals to
pay for a lot of his stuff for him with
a bit of an iou
yeah but there's a reputational cost to
that there's a massive reputational cost
to that there's also the question of
whether or not boris johnson is going to
pay them back and how good it that he is
there's also a bit of an issue with
regards to if you do lend the prime
minister
a sizable amount of money is boris the
type of chat we've seen over history
might try and do you a solid off the
back of that and that's not really any
way to run a country that's quite a low
revenue
kind of lloyd george 19
1917 1918 ish
it's not really 2021 look it's
embarrassing for the country to be
perfectly honest with you that you would
have a prime minister's having to beg
steal and borrow from people
um essentially to pay off uh the fact
that he's got a load of children
we're not legally allowed to report how
many he has that if indeed he doesn't
know how many he has
uh you know i mean it's not great luck
for britain really it's
not not and i wonder if the conservative
party is beginning to
think that but you've not picked any of
that well i'm not particularly that up i
mean it's clear that they're just
rolling the wicket for rishi sunak and
that seems to be the one and then the
conservative party will be able to say
they've had two female leaders for the
first ethnic minority prime minister as
well
kirsten was simply not at the races he
said he's willing to just sweat blood
you know
no other races but he's always playing
the race card yeah yeah that's true yeah
yeah that would certainly
again shoot his fox well it would it
would absolutely
and yet again there would be although as
pretty patel has found
you can be the wrong type of ethnic man
absolutely and a lot of it i thought it
was fascinating actually when when
tyrone ming's english centre-back put
out
he's perfectly entitled to do of course
that you know it didn't feel as though
um
uh as though principal had right really
to kind of congratulate the england team
based on the fact she was
okay okay with them being booed for
taking the knee now she actually said
that it was of individual choice for
people she didn't really
say i'm banging in favor of booing right
but you can imagine around at the patel
household when they took the knee there
was maybe some booing so
and she she kind of she um she basically
obviously copped it now online what i
thought was really interesting was the
racism towards her that was underneath
that
from the so-called kind of tolerant
elements of of society you know
one form of racism seems to be okay and
another form certainly
is not and i found that quite revealing
yeah let's hear from victor
in greenwich go ahead victor good
evening george always a pleasure to hear
you
thank you sir um speaking of racism
this overblown louisiana campaign
trying to win sympathy
for marcus rashford a multi-millionaire
who i think doesn't need our sympathy
he doesn't really seem to be complaining
about these
uh tweets and so forth it's obviously
being blown up by the blairite
brainwashing corporation
and it's allied media pumped out every
day for the last
week they never tell us what exactly
these vile comments really amounted to
though i heard that one of them actually
amounted to
nothing more than asking marcus to go
back to his own country
and as he's born in manchester i'm sure
he's happy to do that
season is obviously a way of bamboozling
our mps
into passing more laws to deny
us more free speech and ensure that the
blair right establishment media
is the only group that's allowed to
express its views on the internet well
look
that's a powerful call uh victor you've
you've come to the wrong place
uh if you want us to diss marcus
rashford because
we're both manchester united fans and
he's one of our heroes so uh we love ira
it would be a rise
sir marcus if it was up to me
but victor's on to something that
actually i have seen it too little
reported that the vast majority
of racist comments following the
failure in the football final yeah were
from
outside of the uk which i think is quite
a suspicious thing in any case
i'm surprised there's not more
speculation
as to where the outside source of this
was
absolutely uh on instagram for example
only four of i think
29 vile instagram postings
actually came from britain which means
the vast majority of them
didn't it's it is all
a little bit of a storm in a teacup
isn't it yeah
i agree i think there was yeah so 70
percent is the figure that i read uh
of these posts of these racist posts
came from outside the country as you
said that's deeply suspicious
it just made one question what the
motivational indeed who was behind all
of that
there is of course the other thing as
well which is that the mule of marcus
rashford that was
vandalized it was graffitied on the
implication of that initially and
everyone just swallowed this was a
foul racist abuse on marcus russia's
mural and it wasn't racist abuse it's
all that that was the police
requirements and it wasn't
endless and i don't get me wrong but it
wasn't racist racially motivated it was
sacrilegious
but it wasn't absolutely disgraced but
it wasn't racist you know
and then and then he said as well there
was a report that came out yesterday
that we've got the highest number of
um race related issues reported to
police
since records began in in this country
and so you look at but that's
reported to police right so that's
people now maybe calling things out or
frankly as well some
sometimes sometimes maybe people
reporting things that don't always
necessarily end up with police action
right so
it's interesting because i think there
seems to be a very very large push at
the moment in this country
to kind of denigrate britain and say
that it is one of the most racist places
in the world
they've obviously never lived in france
well france or america
or america or the netherlands or denmark
or
or australia i could name a hundred and
also let's be honest as well you know
perhaps you know
race relations aren't particularly great
in other parts of the world there's vast
parts of the middle east as well where
you know
there's there might not be necessarily
racist against against people like you
and i but there's racism that goes on
there that might have deeply rose
against people
like you know so there's a lot of racism
in the world and i don't think britain
is unpresent in every
culture and every color anyone who's
lived any length of time anywhere else
already knows that but it's part of the
anti-brexit schtick isn't it yeah
that a carnival of reaction has ensued
yeah when actually uh that's entirely
untrue
uh that the uh england football team
itself
exemplifies a britain that now
is or will be is actually
disproportionately
uh a large number of black and mixed
race people in it
because they're brilliant at football
but the fact that gareth southgate was
the manager of a team that did
really very well until the last and
everybody in the country
loved them you had black people with
england shirts with kane's name on the
back
you had asian people uh you had white
people with rashford's name on the back
and so on uh actually
football is the least racist industry
in britain and britain is the least
racist
country i know yeah debate yeah no i
agree wholeheartedly and i think that
for people as well
they might get a shock if they go
elsewhere i actually feel very sorry for
people
who look through look at everything
through the prism of race-related issues
and see it
all as some kind of whether it's
conscious or indeed unconscious racial
problem i think that's a real shame
because actually a lot of people that
were just watching the football and they
were just watching a [ __ ]
three highly paid footballers missing
penalties
they should easily have scored exactly
exactly but people are very quick now
people are far
too quick to kind of jump on in my
opinion anyway the racial bandwagon
and that diminishes real problems with
racism well it does it devalues the
currency
i was angry at marcus rashford's penalty
and i love him like a son
and the last the last reason why i
was angry was because he was black that
is the least
reason conceivable i was angry because
he fannied around uh with the with his
uh
foolish stuttering run-up and missed
yeah you can only do that if you're
going to score
let's take a call ian and hounslow go
ahead
uh hi george hi um i think we've noticed
but um if you go to some supermarkets
now again you'll see some of the shells
are empty
and the reason is we've got a really bad
uk
trucker shortage and it's getting worse
this is not an aberration no no the
trucker shortage is a real thing a good
friend of mine
uh begal is himself a trucker
and is really struggling to get drivers
for his company so i know it's a real a
real problem go on here
now the the anti-brexit rejoin
eu at any cost cultists are blaming
brexit
uh and they're only talking to business
owners
and managers they're not talking to the
truckers
now the truckers are going on youtube
and giving out like a little monologue
on what's going wrong
and surprise surprise it's pay uh you're
holding the rig
for 10 pounds an hour uh and they had
all these romanians and poles coming in
who they exploited
like some call form of modern slavery
and uh this led to an increase in truck
accidents of 67
i'm one of the victims of just that go
ahead
yes uh and also many of them weren't
even genuine truck drivers or were
banned
or were drunk or drunk
they were so tired that they couldn't
drive straight
exactly because they were working more
hours than they're supposed to
and the rigs weren't in road worthy
condition
so it's interesting that the um
the the eu romaniacs are ignoring the
drivers
who talk about pay conditions not enough
trucks drops
not no infrastructure high insurance
premiums for younger drivers
and the general the general
grind and grit they have to do to hold
down
living and just talk to the managers in
order to
waive that anti-brexit pro-eu banner
that's a brilliant call ian thank you
for that
it is remarkable that they're still
going after all these years
the romaniacs the rejoiners uh uh
people uh i sometimes uh wonder at the
sanity
of some of them the idea that it's
somehow a vote winner to
want to rejoin the eu but it's equally
true
that if british capitalism uh
is having a shortage of labor it's not
you don't need to be einstein to work
out that they've got to put the money up
yeah that's it now this is where i would
expect the government to be quite nimble
on their feet so far grant shaps's
solution to this has been to essentially
allow the drivers to take longer hours
which i think as we all can see there's
there's some quite potential
catastrophic flaws with that and it's
certainly
a sticking plaster and i think the fact
is that if pay is an issue then maybe
that's an area of our economy that we
could help to kind of subsidize
them from the government i did see a
fantastic piece today a picture today
sorry on twitter that highlights exactly
the point that your
wonderful caller there made about
essentially the the the romaniacs there
there was some uh
fruit and vegetables um in tesco's the
aisle that was that was quite
bare and they went this is brexit
britain no
it's the hottest day of the year
everyone's outside of barbecues
they've just bought a load of salad a
lot of ice cream
in one part of london you know that's
kind of where we are now a lot of people
want to jump onto that that particular
bandwagon i do think that seriously that
the
you know the european union fanatics
have been completely undermined by the
fact that we're supposed to be whether
or not it's freedom day and name only
tomorrow
we're supposed to be having freedom day
in this country tomorrow actually
realistically
we wouldn't have anything like the
vaccines will be in a position to have
the kind of
freedoms that we had now if we'd remain
in the european union
undeniably true thank you very much
patrick as always
and uh apologies to jamie lowe for being
late again with the news with jamie law
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news the british prime
minister and chancellor will now
self-isolate after contact with health
secretary
sajid javid who tested positive for
coronavirus
the u-turn comes just hours after they
said they would take part in a pilot
scheme
involving daily testing instead of
self-isolation
opposition parties had said it suggested
there was one rule for them and another
for the rest of us
downing street said boris johnson will
conduct meetings remotely at his country
residents
checkers chancellor rissy sunak said on
twitter whilst the test and trace pilot
is fairly restrictive
allowing only essential government
business i recognize that even the sense
that the rules aren't the same for
everyone is wrong labour leader shakir
stamos said the prime minister and
chancellor had been busted yet again for
thinking the rules that we are all
following don't apply to them
supermarkets have warned that they will
have to cut opening hours or even shut
shops if the number of workers forced to
self-isolate continues to
rise marks and spencer said the number
of workers being notified by the nhs app
is rising exponentially
and it may have to reduce hours if there
are shortages
another leading supermarket said it
could lead to massive disruption of food
supplies
quote and there's a risk that there
won't be sufficient staff to open
shops last week over 500 000 alerts were
sent to users
of the nhs test and trace app in england
and wales for the week
to the 7th of july a rise of 46
on the previous week from the 16th of
august people who have been fully
vaccinated will not have to
self-isolated if they are pinged by the
nhs app
when they have come into contact with
someone who has tested positive for
covid
however fully vaccinated travellers
returning to scotland from france
will still have to quarantine despite
rules changing
from monday adults who have been double
jabbed in the uk arriving from abolish
countries will not need to isolate for
days but the scottish government said
those returning from france would still
have to isolate this is because of
concerns that vaccines may not work as
well
against the beta variant the beta
variant accounts for about 10
of new infections in france but that
includes the indian ocean territories
of reunion and mayotay where the variant
is near universal the more infectious
delta variant first identified in india
accounts for almost
all new cases in the uk under the new
rules those coming back to scotland from
france will need to stay
in their own accommodation and take a
test on the second and eighth day
of their isolation period even if
they've had both doses of the vaccine
eight members of team gb have been
forced into isolation
after coming into contact with a covert
case on their flight to the tokyo
olympics the six athletes and two
members of staff tested
negative before departure and upon
arrival in japan but have since been
identified as a close contact of an
infected person who shared their journey
on thursday that person
is not a member of team gb the british
olympic association said
german chancellor angela merkel has
expressed shock at what she described as
surreal destruction
caused by last week's flooding merkel
visited affected areas of western
germany on sunday talking to survivors
and emergency workers
at least 184 people in belgium and
germany are now known to have died in
the floods heavy rain is continuing to
wreak havoc with the tension now
shifting to parts of austria
and southern germany emergency crews
rescued people from homes in the
austrian region of salzburg
where floodwaters submerged the streets
of one town the capital vienna
saw more rainfall in an hour on saturday
night than in the previous
seven weeks in western germany
authorities said steinbach till dam
southwest of bonn remained at risk of
breaching
after residents were evacuated from
homes downstream
european leaders have blamed climate
change for the floods which have also
affected switzerland
luxembourg and the netherlands the widow
of haiti's assassinated president has
returned to the caribbean nation after
being treated
in florida for wounds suffered in the
attack martine moisie was seen wearing
an arm sling
and a bulletproof vest after arriving by
plane at port-au-prince airport
yesterday
her husband gervanelle moisey was killed
by assassins
in their home on the 7th of july the u.s
singer britney spears has said she will
not perform again whilst her father
retains control over her career
as part of a conservative ship set up in
2008.
the singer's message is the latest in a
series of emotional public comments
about the arrangement
that controls her personal and financial
affairs
quote this conservative ship killed my
dreams she said in a lengthy post on
instagram
so all i have is hope the conservative
ship was put in place
after her father jamie spears petitioned
a court for legal authority over the pop
star's life amid concerns about her
mental health
brittany added quote i'm not going to be
performing to any stages anytime
soon with my dad handling what i wear
say do or think
she has not appeared in public since
2018.
and finally kazunori takashima traveled
the world to support japan at every
olympic games for the past
15 years so it was a dream to see the
event in his home city of tokyo
he spent almost 40 thousand dollars on
197 tickets for him and friends but
when a ban on spectators was announced
last week due to covert 19 that dream
died quote it took an unbelievable
amount of time
effort and passion takashima said but i
was so passionate about the olympics
that even though it was very difficult
and challenging i enjoyed the process of
buying the tickets
the 45 year old businessman worked out
that if he watched all the events he had
booked he would have broken the guinness
world record for attendance
at the olympic games quote all i have
now is sadness
and every time i look at the tickets i
cry takashima said i am just
sad he will however get a refund for
those tickets but because of covid
only members of the media and selected
dignitaries will be allowed to watch the
events this year's games which open
on friday delayed from summer 2020 due
to the coronavirus pandemic
and that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm joey lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio now it was a glittering occasion
in north london last evening
in moswell hill to be exact in the
everyman cinema a wonderful
wonderful cinema i wonder how long it
will be allowed to call itself
every man maybe it will be the every
person
cinema but a truly wonderful jewel of a
place
it is and there in front of a very
distinguished audience indeed
we introduced as the premiere of
my latest film killing kelly which was
crowdfunded
by many of you this rather beautiful
poster
is available dot shop
uh in fact you can pre-order the dvd if
you haven't already done so
by visiting george galloway dot shop or
you can
rent it for four pounds online on vimeo
uh or
you can buy it for six pounds uh on
vimeo and a very large number of people
have already done so so much so that the
uh the system collapsed
on the demand there's the address
vimeo.com
forward slash on demand slash
killing kelly that's vimeo.com
forward slash on demand forward slash
killing kelly or you can just go on my
twitter feed it's being
discussed by very many people there
as i said uh earlier it took some
courage
to make the film but not nearly as much
as it took my next guest to write the
book
that inspired the film he is the right
honorable
norman baker and he's in i think this
promo
two minutes long watch it just remember
back in 2002 2003
there was a wish by george bush for
regime change
that's what was driving him nothing to
do with weapons and mass destruction
which of course didn't exist
in iraq so they had to construct some
sort of
formula some sort of cover story in
order to persuade the british public
that intervention in iraq was right
now david kelly as an expert in weapons
of mass destruction
knew that uh this was untrue he knew
that there were probably no weapons of
mass structure
in iraq that was a guy that could have
brought down
i was going to brought down the whole
system i reckon you're a chat
you've been thrown up to deve to our
probing
the foreign affairs select committee
that um
parliamentarian briefing i think that
was an indignity to him
saw it on the news and my very first
thought was shock
oh my god you know this man is in the
eye of the media hurricane
he should be protected by that at least
i don't know
the details of how lord hutton happened
to be
selected but what was certainly the case
is that he was the right kind of judge
to use from the point of view of dining
street and the intelligence services as
well
after 21 days of hearing only one
half of one day was spent on discussing
the forensic aspects
that is disgusting we were given the
hutton report the day before
it was published but actually what
happened was
he went too far the events of 2003
were disgraceful ones in this country's
history and its unfinished business
those responsible for an illegal war
those responsible for the death of david
kelly
have not been brought to justice there's
been no inquest
into david kelly's death there needs to
be one
we need to make sure that those who
behaved
in a reprehensible way in 2003 i finally
brought the book
daring and powerful words from the right
honourable norman baker my
parliamentary colleague for some time
now in the radio business like me
and the executive producer of the film
killing kelly out from last evening
and going like hot cakes norman thank
you very much for
joining us again this evening and thank
you for coming to north london
for the q a last night
which you perform magnificently in
everyone
uh said so after you'd gone
so let me ask the the first question
where did you find the moral fiber and
resolve courage
to write the book when you did when it
was still
a pretty dangerous thing to do you might
have been found in the woods yourself
well i mean some strange things happened
to me but george i don't think i was
particularly showing courage i was
probably being rather foolhardy at the
time
i was incensed that he was a man who
had performed great things not just for
this country but for the world
who had been trashed openly by the
government
of the day uh who's never been
deliberately leaked uh to the media in
the feeding frenzy
um and yet when he died suddenly
uh the press in this country the useless
press in this country
failed to look into that matter at all
and were led off by eliza campbell to
look into the faults
of the exports of the bbc and the
the third estate in this country the
third or fourth estate the press
underwent the media
just really performed so badly that i
thought well don't
investigating this matter then i will
because someone had to
and uh every time you picked up a stone
there was something nasty falling
underneath
yes and leading on to more and more
stones and
uh the film adam breaks them up very
well the director
sean murray has made a real silk
purse of what you and i were able to
give them uh it wasn't a salsier we gave
them but it's much prettier now
artistically in the final form of the
film i heard you say so last night
it's one damn thing after another
to paraphrase mr macmillan uh
it's the lack of fingerprints on
the knife on the phone on the water
bottle
the lack of blood by the corpse
for a man that would have had to shed
almost all of his blood
to die in the way that the hutton
inquiry concluded
that he had died it was the picking
of this uh trustee
lord hutton to do the inquiry the
abandonment of the age old right to an
inquest
and so on one thing after another as we
watched it last night
and marveled at just how many reasons to
disbelieve
the official story there were
absolutely and just to pick up on their
fingerprints of course it's worth
mentioning as i did last night that
the fact that there were no fingerprints
in the night was not discovered by lord
hatton
such a basic question it was recovered
by me through a freedom
of information requests it's not my job
to do that was lord hutton's job to do
that
but he failed miserably to do so and i
think you've listed some of the problems
george i mean there are so many problems
we could
we could spend half an hour listing all
the inaccuracies
inconsistencies and and ludicrous
conclusions reached in the hutton report
uh in that so-called inquiry which of
course had no statutory basis
whatsoever but you know the the sad
thing is
that the public and parliament were
treated with contempt
by the government of the day and they
got away with it
he absolutely got away with it and
almost 20 years on
we still have had no end question to
mckenna's death
absolutely and although we are journey
men
working men in our prime working in the
media
the people responsible for all these
things have little need to work
as we know it they are
multi-millionaires
they've all been promoted norma
well one of the sadnesses of the whole
episode uh and i come to this at the end
of my book the strange ethnic david
kelly was that the people who did to try
to do the right thing
in 2003 people like greg dyke gavin
davis
andrew gilligan all phantom stars out of
a job
turfed out uh forced to resign uh andrew
and andrew mckinley the labour mp was in
the film
who tried to do the right thing as well
was was
was turned into some sort of
by the media as if he was responsible
for david kennedy's death
and the people who are responsible for
the shocking events of 2003 people like
tony blair
and jack straw and alexa campbell they
all prospered
and tony blair then went right he was
when he was stopped being prime minister
he was told by
george bush he was going to be making
pre-salon right i'll make you peace and
void the middle east
go and make some money and tony blair
they went around the world with a
t-shirt on a bit like mine was saying
for sale
on the t-shirt what did nothing divide
away from a former premise today
here's a poll we've got up at norman how
do you believe
dr david kelly died a suicide
b assassination c
some other reason people can vote on my
twitter feed now
uh if you were voting on that poll how
would you vote
well that's what i wrote b or c if you
don't know but i certainly wouldn't vote
a
i am convinced beyond reasonable doubt
to use that legal test
but there's no way that david kelly
could have could have committed suicide
based on the medical evidence
based on the state of mind based on the
based on the timeline
it simply wasn't possible and it's an
insult to the population at large to
believe
he did and of course let's just think
about a proper corners inquest which
there wasn't one the coroner began his
inquest
and was bonded off the case by the
government how dare the government do
they
stop a coroner investigating a matter
through an inquest is this what we've
come to in this country
it apparently is and apparently they get
away with it and we were suppressed
complaining about this
nowhere but had the caller's inquest
taken place
legally in order to reach a verdict of
suicide
you have to be convinced beyond
reasonable doubt that suicide
needs explanation i challenge anyone in
this country anyone
to tell me that beyond reasonable doubt
david kelly committed suicide
so for our nonsense yes
uh but there's only the and me uh still
talking about it and the 1500 people
that
crowdfunded the film we must hope
that the release of the film uh as it
were rekindles
interest in this case not just because
of the importance of
david kelly and i concur with your
piano of praise to him earlier but
because of what it all means
for the britain we thought we had
our institutions that we thought we had
which have all been shot through by the
blair government in the run-up to
and since 2003's invasion of iraq
yes immense damage has been done
government
apparently can now lie to parliament to
take us into an illegal war
uh government can ignore proper
processes in terms of inquests
which have been well established over
centuries actually
inquests government can ignore freedom
of information request for this
government now the boris johnson
is increasingly doing a government can
in fact lay the blame on the independent
bbc
and pretend it's all their fault if
kelly died
i mean what are shambles and how do we
put up with this but that's where we got
to in this country
the pillars of democracy have been
knocked down one by one
no one's noticed and no one's rebuilding
them
now how do people get your book it's
still in print
i know that you had three with you last
night they were snapped up
in about three seconds uh a lot of
people would still like to read it
norman uh even though uh there have been
other books
uh yours was the trail blazer uh how
would someone
buy it now is it online yes it's online
and it's available in all good book
shops and no doubt some
ropey ones as well um it's published by
methuen
um it was reprinted it's been reprinted
many times
and the last reprint happened i think in
january so it's it's around again
uh it's there and i hope very much if i
can come and
share some more events with you george
i'll come and bring some along to yes
we will be taking the film around the
country with that q and a format at the
end
uh so i very much hope that you'll join
us we're not a bad double act
for two political enemies uh the right
honorable
norman baker george actually i don't
know
i'm just uh i'm pulling your leg not at
all you're
you're a hero of mine in fact and not
just for that book
norman thank you for joining us on the
film
at the event last night and again on the
show this evening
i hurry you on because there's a very
large number of callers
want to talk about the issues uh
this evening now you can pre-order uh
the dvd
at george galloway dot shop and you can
download the video by going to
vimeo.com forward slash on demand
forward slash
killing kelly now do
i have a question for you
in 1959 ed woods
cult classic movie plan 9 from outer
space
you've obviously seen it premiered and
was hailed
as what a sci-fi brilliance
be revelatory see
the worst movie ever made
answer after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
now don't forget you can download the
podcast of this program
a finely edited highlights version of
this three-hour epic
it's being listened to now all around
the world huge numbers
are downloading the as it were compact
version of the show of course in the uk
and the us but listen to these countries
that downloaded it last week japan
india denmark saudi arabia
korea switzerland uae
and hong kong in china all of those had
significant audiences of last week's
show search moats m-o-a-t-s
on the app where you get your podcast
from
[Music]
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
1959 ed woods cult classic movie plan 9
from outer space
which all of us have seen and marveled
at
was hailed as the worst movie
ever made although i think the
flintstones which i
mistakenly forced my children to watch
just the other night would run it close
let's look at the early results on the
poll
how do you believe dr david kelly died a
suicide
11 b assassination
81 c some other reason
8 extraordinary numbers there
i hope aleister campbell is watching
renato silva says the anc changed
radically at least 10 years ago
and gambine now we says
asians have always been the gatekeepers
for white racism towards blacks
in south africa i certainly don't
associate with that
inflammatory claim
and uh mal in perth in western australia
says i hope you're well great show again
i was awake again waiting for your live
broadcast on youtube
i was watching a documentary only a few
days ago about the so-called wmd
and the spin and propaganda of powell
and romsfeld
and bush jr i can't believe the brass
neck of these people
how they said all this while keeping a
straight face
it had nothing to do with wmd it was all
about regime change as saddam hussein
had gone
past his cell by date and he was no more
used to the usa
it's a disgrace what has happened in
iraq
and elsewhere in the middle east thank
you
very much for that mal in western
australia and particularly
for getting up so early to watch it
and jk says an envoy of the cia was in
talks
with bolsonaro some two weeks ago here
in brazil too and jack klugman
says funny that the cia director met
with the colombian leadership
days before the assassination of the
president
of haiti let's take some calls steve in
liverpool
on cuba go ahead steve
yes yes
yes thank you for having me on the show
george
can you hear me yes i can everyone can
hear you go ahead
yeah just want to mention about cuba
yeah
about the uh about the mainstream media
and the us administration
the way they use the same rhetoric with
the united states
against cuba just like they did in syria
libya to establish regime change
in them countries i agree with
i agree with the totally agree with
caleb martin
what was correct by saying this is just
being played out
uh just like for all the yeah it's a
playbook isn't it
yeah yeah it's
quite correct they did it in all those
places and 50 more
uh around the the world but i think as
ronnie castrol's put earlier in the show
they've come up against a hard rock
in cuba they will not be able to swallow
cuba uh that i
confidently assert steve what about you
yes i i totally agree because there's
been
there's a mass movement that in cuba
yeah
yeah millions and millions and they've
all got guns by the way steve
thanks for the call john is in
massachusetts on the same
subject go ahead john
um hi actually that was calling
about you more
talk about south africa too yes
i have a theory i wanted to run by you
about the reason they started this
colored revolution now because i learned
to
i don't think it has prayer of
succeeding in cuba
but today our primary election in chile
and the communist candidate
um was leading
by a considerable margin
during the week to be one of the two
victims
the victor of the left
i've lost that i'm afraid uh john will
have to try and get back to you
uh another uh time uh now
uh so much here how do i
pick fahim khan says what happened to
the scandal
involving the gupta family and jacob
zuma well ronnie touched
on that a few times in the report
bat think says if george is really a
hero
why doesn't he get to the bottom of
freemasonry
in government ah
you've rumbled me that thing and tour
guide says the biggest victims of
xenophobic
attacks are against black africans from
other south african countries such as
zimbabwe
and shahid says he will go again blame
the poor for standing up to the rich
that are robbing the country dry so what
if they are looting
wouldn't you if you had to feed your
kids and had been left
to rot and just say
says uk war mongers work
with the cia and fbi just look at julian
assange for example
and david rayner says try socialism so
everyone can be equally poor apart from
the party
of course and sir lord balti on the pole
says unfortunately yes i fight crime at
night
so it's a requirement puzzled me
i don't know if it puzzled you we've got
john
back on the line from massachusetts
sorry about that john it was a bad line
go ahead
okay i uh what i was saying i don't know
how much you heard before but after the
beginning again
okay one explanation for the timing of
this
attempted color revolution in cuba
is that this weekend in chile
they're having a very important round of
the presidential election
where they will choose the final
candidates for november's race
and for the first time in history the
communist party's candidate
a man named daniel xiaodu is
uh was considerably ahead in the polls
interesting i didn't know that i didn't
know that john
and uh of course all over latin america
the press is dominated
by right-wing owned
publications and it's been just a
constant
stream um
accusatory uh reports about the misery
and communist cuba and it's not
um i don't think the people of chile
will be deceived
given their own history and their own
struggles
and the fact that this candidate has a
history of being a
known era of a major metropolitan hero
area
my experience of chilean people is that
there are few people
anywhere in the world as politically
sophisticated as
them john thanks for getting back to us
now dr david whitehouse is a doctor
of astrophysics and an author
and he's kindly agreed to join us
on this the anniversary of the moon
landing
if indeed the moon landing happened dr
david i'm only joking
thank you very much indeed for joining
us
but one of my friends did say he was
only joking too
are we really sure they did land on the
moon let's crush that
canard right right up top did they
of course they did i mean the evidence
is overwhelming half a million people
saw them
take off um
a million more than a million people
were involved in the mission
the people who went there told us
stories
we have rocks coming back from the moon
which are different from earth rocks
and when we put satellites around around
the moon
look down on the surface of the moon we
can see what they left behind we can
almost even see
their footprints we can certainly see
the tire tracks of the rovers they left
behind
consistent with the missions they
performed if you want a conspiracy
theory
there are better candidates than we
didn't go to the moon
indeed so and isn't it the case
that the computing power in this
telephone
is greater than the computing power
that landed these two men on the moon
you are quite right
um even before we had smartphones
the computer power in in dumb phones was
much more sophisticated
than the apollo landing computer which
was at the time
a work of art a tremendous
piece of equipment and they couldn't
have landed performed a mission without
it so it was state of the art at the
time but you're right things have moved
on
so much not only in terms of computing
but in terms of materials in terms of
almost everything to do with space 50
years ago space was
you know really touched our lives now
it's intertwined with almost everything
we do
well for someone my age space was simply
magical we thrilled to be to the
sputnik to the moon mission uh
to tell star and and all of that it was
a truly uh a major part of my young life
i wonder
why we moved on uh so far i mean
there are space missions going on all
the time including
the chinese landing on the dark side of
the moon for example they get virtually
no coverage nowadays
why is that well you're quite right
things are different these days you
haven't got a race between the super
powers to get to the moon
as you did in in the 60s although
there is a new race starting it with
many right runners at the moment with
uh with russia and china america
and the entrepreneurs in america elon
musk jeff bezos richard branson etc
things are changing um but you're quite
right i've i've often felt
for many years people worked hard to
make space
boring uh it isn't boring there's a
great deal going on and
and and if you if what you're saying is
that it doesn't have the right level
of appreciation in our culture
um in the west as as much as perhaps it
should do i would agree with you this is
a
tremendous story that fertilizes so much
of our society
which we should all be thrilled about
and we should all
appreciate quite so uh now
have we forgotten about the moon largely
because
there isn't all that much that we can
now learn
from the moon and that other targets
that are now within reach
the rovers on mars and so on uh
have greater potential to
change the way that we look at life and
the origins of it
change the way that we look at the
universe
well there's a lot of what you say there
i mean certainly
if you compare the moon and mars mars
is a true new world it's the first
new world of the cosmos it's unlike the
moon it has an
atmosphere it has uh clouds it has winds
it has
morning dew it has a a wet
past and might even be there might even
be life clinging onto its surface
so the rovers going around on its
surface on the future missions
could actually tell us if there's life
on another planet
uh in our solar system and that would be
tremendous
but mars is very far away and as far as
people are concerned
it will be going back to the moon first
and whatever you say about president
trump
and a lot has been said he did actually
get nasa to speed up and
and get to the moon much sooner than
their
their plan for later on in this decade
so
at last uh 50 years after the over 50
years 52 years after the first footprint
on the moon
um there are people in training for
a mission in just a few years time to go
back to the moon
where we will have a base by the end of
this decade
and as you imply people will go to mars
in the decade after that yes
isn't the trump space force
type propaganda
troubling though under people
particularly in the united states they
may be elsewhere also
i would like to militarize space would
like to militarize the moon
that would be a very dangerous thing
wouldn't it well actually
it's already happening it's already
happened the united states
spends far more money on the military
aspect of space than it ever has
on sending people to the moon on
building the space shuttle on flying
and operating the international space
station it's just that it's not
um it's not obvious uh it's not out in
the open
uh but but spy satellites electronics
and electronic satellites
they um they are more plentiful they
cost a lot more
um they're more sophisticated than i
think many people realize
and what trump did was actually he
brought that out in the open
and said some people agreed with them
many did not
that the military aspect of space should
be
if you like under a new umbrella instead
of being under the air force
so really the american space force is
is little that is new but it's been if
you like
assembled under a new banner instead of
being the space division of the air
force it's now
the space force um so it's it's good in
a sense that um
it has now more visibility many people
are talking about it but let's not kid
ourselves
all nations uh indeed from the very word
go
have more interest the chinese the
russians the the americans
um the british all nations have had more
interest and spent more money on the
military and security aspects of space
and they will continue to do so
than they ever have on the laudable
human exploration of space and the moon
one thing we could never have imagined
back in the 1960s
is that anyone other than a state actor
and
a very powerful state actor could
actually
do these kind of things but as you
pointed out earlier
we're now in the air a era in which
private capitalists are able to amass
the kind of wealth
that can fuel their own private space
programs i mean is it conceivable
that we'll see richard branson on the
moon
and if so can we leave them there
um well you're quite right in the last
20 years we have seen
um billionaires who have the financial
muscle to do this and we never had that
before
spacex with elon musk is a is a
tremendous company that started from
scratch and made
nasa look slow and has developed a suite
of rockets which are um
world beating and which are now cheaper
and starting to make make profits they
can fly to the international space
station
and he can sell his taxi service
to nasa um for a profit
in a way that wasn't done before and yes
the extension of this
is is to go to the moon nasa has already
chosen elon musk's spacex as the
preferred candidate to build
the craft which is going to land on the
moon in a few years time
the other expert in the billionaire in
the running jeff bezos isn't happy about
that and there's currently a legal
dispute between the two
but you're quite right things have
changed no longer will it be
if you like a government going um the
government will go but it will outsource
the construction of the rocket and the
capsule to private enterprise
and that hopefully will make things
cheaper for governments
um employ more people
and hopefully we'll get somewhere
because you know it's been 52 years
since we walked on the moon it's about
time we went back
quite so uh dr whitehouse thanks a
fascinating
uh resume of what's happened in those
decades now since
uh my compatriot neil armstrong
became the first man on the moon your
compatriot too if i've judged your
accent
correctly are you scottish
i'm afraid i am not my family
i come from the midlands and my family
is is welsh
okay i'll take credit but i won't hold
it against you that you're scottish
i'll take credit for neil armstrong in
that case
dr david whitehouse many thanks for
joining us
on the mother of all talk shows let's
take some calls
uh from cynthia in westminster go ahead
cynthia
hi george hi i was listening to your
conversation
with your colleague a couple of hours
ago uh in relation to the football
match oh yeah generally talking about
racism yes
in the uk and it's like really
frustrating to be
a black woman in the 50s i've lived
through
five decades had all sorts of kind of
experiences of racism
i think the issue really is white people
i feel that you just need to be honest
with yourselves
in terms of how you treat
ethnic minorities in the uk i mean it's
always
we're always in this discussion where
it's denied that it doesn't take place
but it does
have and constantly has an impact
on black and brown people's lives
emotionally economically and on a
day-to-day basis
at the moment i'm actually sort of
moving because i live in quite a middle
class area and i'm actually moving
from that area because i'm
one of the few sort of black people that
live there
and on a daily day-to-day basis as i
leave my front door
i experienced this thing called
microaggressions which you probably
don't really understand
that's just generally i'd like to
understand tell us about some of them
well it's just generally you're just
made to feel unwelcome
spoken quite rude to um
it's just generally a general coldness
um because i'm
a black woman professional living in a
sort of a wealthy area i'm not supposed
to be there
there's just sort of a general
undercurrent in britain
in which black people are just made to
feel like second-class citizens and it's
not because
as your colleague says oh i feel so
sorry for
you know people that walk around feeling
you know they've been discriminated
against i go about my day
like any other individual contributing
working hard
but i'm constantly reminded by racist
white people
that i'm different that i you know i can
be treated in an underhand way if this
thing called institutional racism which
exists
it exists when you go to the bank if you
want to sort of you know extend your
mortgage or
you know get a business loan it's just
everywhere and i think you know
white brits just need to have an honest
conversation with themselves
we're ready to have that with you
unfortunately the
hour is late but let me just uh respond
if i may uh
nobody is saying certainly not me that
there is no racism in britain how could
it be
that there was no racism in britain we
were an imperial
colonial uh empire uh
that uh that uh was built upon the
concept of racial superiority after all
if we were not
the superior of the places we were
conquering and exploiting uh
garrisoning and in the era of slavery
taking the very people from those lands
themselves
then that's racism that's the root
of racism and we could hardly be exempt
from it my point was
that of all the countries i know
racism is less here
than it is in those other countries
that there is less now than there was
i assure you of that uh when i was
young and living in a place where there
were no people
of color i mean i would be a teenager
before i
saw a person of color
but there was plenty of racism
in people's discourse in the
television shows that were on in the
casual conversation even of
of well-meaning people so britain is
less racist than the other countries
britain is less racist now than it was
and the england football team
and the way that the whole country fell
in love with
it is an example
of that last word to you cynthia i mean
that's not good enough if you're a tax
paying hard-working black person
who continuously sees that you're at
disadvantage because of white people's
attitudes
to the color of your skin it's not good
enough that we
still are in the economic position we
are in because we suffer discrimination
in the workplace
employment matters etcetera what we
now live under is a system of covert
racial discrimination it's
it's hidden it's denied but it still
hasn't it's illegal of course
it's illegal yeah well it's still it
still has an insidious
insidious effect on our life chances
you know why is it that you know black
women are five more
you know five times more likely to die
in the nhs
when they give birth to children why is
it that we have a disproportionate of
number of young men black men in
prison in the criminal justice system
white people in britain
you know you need to stop telling
yourselves that you're not racist and
you're better than every other country
well we are better than every other
country
tell me a country that's better yeah but
that means nothing to me
well it may not that means something to
me
and my children because we live here
we're born here
i've been here you know we've been here
long enough we've done the wind rush we
work you know we were in this first
world war second world war
it's about time that you look at
yourselves
and change your attitudes and stop being
so ignorant we're human beings
we deserve to be treated fairly like
everyone else
this country is supposed to be highly
educated
highly superior and it's all it's arts
and history but you know what there's
one thing it's not good at
it's not good at being fair and kind to
all the nations that have contributed to
its wealth
whether in slavery or otherwise and i
just feel that you know
you know this football match really hit
home you know the first thing that came
out of their mouths was
bananas and monkeys and everything
stopped being in denial why was that
why was it their first instinct they
didn't see a 19 year old boy
they didn't see a 23 year old that had
helped to sort of you know
feed and support children in poverty all
they saw was the color of this
skin some foul beasts did that you're
right
but the number of them was small and
the vast majority of them were from
outside of the united kingdom
which is the point that i was making but
listen
uh are you still there i i want to ask
you something cynthia
it's a difficult question i'm sorry i
have to ask it
yeah is racism only something that
happens
from white people because we both know
that it is not
we both know that there is racism
between other races also including in
this country
we both know that some black people
stab other black people because those
other
black are blacker than them yeah so
this is not just about white people is
it yeah but it is
because you you know a white man or a
white
female in the situation that we live in
has the power to
impact whether i get a mortgage when my
kid goes to a school can we deal with
the stabbing
and well that is you know at the end of
the day
it's about power someone you know an
asian man being a racist against
me is not going to have that much of an
impact
on my life than a racist bank clerk that
decides oh
what about the large number of black
people that are murdering other black
people can you answer that
white people murder other white people
why is it why do you narrow it down to
color that's
example of the racism that i'm dealing
with well
there's nothing racist about it it's a
fact a fact
cannot be racist it might be a symphony
a
majority of people stabbed to death in
london
last year were black people stabbed by
other black people
that's a fact that might have nothing to
do with discrimination it might
it might have to do with disputes what
i'm talking about is the fact that
you know anonymous individuals will
you know will harass me will affect my
economic development
simply because they've got this
ingrained ignorant
foolishness in their mind that when they
look at me they don't see a human being
they see something that they think is
less than them
you know and at the end of the day that
is a white man's problem a white woman's
problem it's about time you stop
ignoring it and denying it
and deal with it you're causing a lot of
harm i'm causing a lot of harm thank you
for that call
ali is in sweden uh let's hear from him
last call go ahead ali
hey what's up george lovely seeing you
mate right there
okay yeah i just want to
like yeah i'm totally like i i counter
i counter that woman which is saying
like i'm an immigrant myself and i'm
born a racist
i mean you don't you don't have you
don't have it like that doesn't matter
it's not because
of a white guy or whatever you have
problems because of policies
it's paul it's political that's why you
have divisions and stuff it's not
because of my race
and things like that i mean that's just
silly that's absolutely
crazy argument i mean if some guy looked
at you funny like
so like okay sure like yeah you'll meet
once upon a like in life you'll you'll
meet people there
maybe not that are not nice but it
doesn't matter
that's not what what makes it i don't
put everyone in the same you know in the
same basket and call them all racists
and crap
i mean what kind of freaking ludicrous
talking crap is this
it's just insane like what the hell is
going on
specific talking about a coldness uh
talking about uh bank issues
and mortgage issues uh and so on
now we don't know anything about those
issues in relation to
cynthia they might be personal
maybe she was refused something or
treated
in a way that was personal my own
uh my own take is ali
that wealthy professionals living
in areas where professionals live
seldom suffer over racism
good night
[Music]
you